he's Fearless he's eccentric he's
dedicated to the SCP foundation's cause
in a lot of ways he's even more like a
living legend than a regular Foundation
employee his face voice gender and even
species may sometimes change but it's
impossible to miss that ornate Medallion
resting against his chest that's right
today we're talking about the infamous
Dr bright can you think of many other
researchers who've been cross-tested
with the dreaded scp-682 and live to
tell the tale of course there's a
special Advantage Dr bright possesses
that most researchers don't it's The
Medallion he's never seen without and
because of it Dr bright can't die how is
that possible you ask because in a sense
he is that Medallion don't worry after
this crash course in all things Dr
bright including his origin his present
and his future you'll be a lot less
confused so who is Dr Jack Bright for
starters he's a decorated researcher of
anomalies for the SCP Foundation and
unlike most other researchers he's
uniquely qualified for the job on the
grounds that he himself is an anomaly
just don't bring this up when you're
talking to him it's kind of a sore
subject beyond that who or even what Dr
bright is can be a bit of a loaded
question with an answer that depends on
who and when you ask what we're
presenting to you here is one of the
more popular versions of the Dr Bright's
story and the one most closely adhered
to by Dr bright himself these days one
of our biggest challenges to
understanding Dr bright is that he has
been so prolific in his exploits and
achievements within the foundation that
when telling his story it's hard to know
where to start but as the saying goes
let's begin at the beginning starting
with the bright family bright was a name
that carried a lot of weight around the
foundation even before Jack bride signed
up for service his parents Dr Adam and
Evelyn bright were both Foundation
Personnel his siblings were incredibly
numerous and the ones we were aware of
are TJ bright Michael bright Claire
Pierce and a nameless sister now known
only as scp-321 sadly you'll soon see
that the story of the bright family is
one of consistent tragedy and strife
while the anomalization of Dr bright
took hold a little later on in his life
his brother TJ was born anomalous and
was designated as
scp-590 TJ had the ability to heal any
ailment with a touch with the cost being
that he took on those ailments himself
he's now used as a tool for healing at
the foundation and he's consistently
bedridden with the illnesses he takes on
Dr bright induced a mental state similar
to that of a three-year-old in TJ likely
in hopes of reducing the mental burden
placed on his poor brother and sadly
that burden goes far beyond healing the
illnesses of strangers when Adam and
Evelyn experienced a tragic stillbirth
they desperately tried to get TJ to help
TJ did manage to save her partially but
the result wasn't human and both he and
the daughter which came to be known as
scp-321 were taken into Foundation
custody
scp-321 was a highly regenerative and
stretched out Abomination that seemed to
keep growing with age but Adam still saw
it as his daughter and spent the rest of
his life trying to negotiate her freedom
from the foundation when his request was
denied as a researcher he climbed the
ranks to Personnel director when his
request was denied there he became a
site director and then a member of the
o5 council all with the intention of
getting his daughter back but that never
happened and the rest of the council had
him assassinated for his trouble there's
no reward for sentimentality at the
foundation the other two bright siblings
are believed to be Polar Opposites
Michael Bryant is one of the
foundation's best field agents known to
some as agent Cowboy his dedication to
the cause and incredible aptitude at his
job has led some to speculate that he
may even be on the o5 council already
Claire Pierce on the other hand
disagrees with the actions of the
foundation on a fundamental level which
is understandable given the horrific
things they've done to the bright family
she defected and became a member of the
Serpent's hand a fringe group dedicated
to blowing the lid on SCP Foundation
Secrets this brings us to the man
himself Dr bright the most well-known
member of this sprawling family much
like most of the rest of his family he
too entered the employment of the SCP
Foundation he was a junior researcher
and a relatively unremarkable one until
his fateful run-in with a certain
necklace labeled
scp-963 but what is
scp-963 and how exactly did Dr bright
come into contact with it it all started
in a small apartment that was raided by
the found Foundation due to supposed
occult activities there they found a
single body cause of death apparently
from suicide clutching The Medallion
that would later be designated as
scp-963 the walls in the apartment were
covered in ritualistic Supernatural
symbols and a number of occult books
were also found near the deceased man's
body the foundation gathered that the
man was attempting to perform some kind
of magical ritual but had apparently
failed leading to his own demise the
foundation soon learned that the
recovered Medallion appeared to be
utterly indestructible and they placed
it under the care of a junior researcher
one Dr Jack Bryant Dr bright studied The
Medallion for years with very little to
show for it until one fateful day when
he was tasked with transporting The
Medallion to a different area of the
containment facility while Dr bright was
carrying out his simple transport task
he made a simple decision that changed
the entire course of his life forever he
held The Medallion in in his bare hand
he also happened to be walking past the
containment chamber of
scp-076-2 AKA Abel just as a Containment
Breach was about to occur able is an
immortal hyper-violent Warrior who can
summon blades out of interdimensional
portals Dr bright following in the
tradition of the bright family bad luck
happened to be right in the path of
Abel's Rampage the ensuing battle
between Abel and the assembled mobile
task forces and guards resulted in the
destruction of the entire wing of the
facility and Dr bright was cut down in
the Brawl by The Warriors Supernatural
blades it seemed like the story of Dr
bright was short and simple cut down in
this Prime in the line of duty but a few
days later as several members of d-class
personnel were cleaning up the mess
caused by the Containment Breach one
unlucky d-class known as d-113 happened
upon The Medallion that Dr bright had
been holding when he died he leaned over
and picked it up and instantly on
underwent a sudden and drastic change in
personality
d113 was now insisting that he was Dr
bright and since this d-class had no
reason to even know of the recently
deceased researcher's existence he was
immediately brought in for an interview
after a brief evaluation it seemed clear
that somehow this d-class really did
have the exact mind of Jack Bright but
how well after some experimentation
including from Dr bright himself they
found the answer the medallion's purpose
was to act as a kind of vessel for the
consciousness of the person killed
holding it its original Creator had
hoped to use it as a way to attain
immortality and took his own life in
order to complete the ritual this was a
mistake though the correct way to
complete the ritual was being killed by
someone else while holding The Medallion
something that had happened to Dr bright
by total accident in a sense he'd been
given a second chance at life but this
came with some anomalous side effects as
it turns out coming into direct contact
with the necklace now known as
scp-963-1 is a death sentence it causes
your mind to be totally wiped and
replaced with that of Dr bright if the
necklace is then removed you become a
lifeless husk until the necklace is
placed back onto you if The Medallion
remains in contact with its hose for a
period of 30 days Dr Bright's
Consciousness becomes permanently bonded
to the body without any contact from The
Medallion if The Medallion then comes
into contact with someone else even if a
permanent version of Dr bright is
already inhabiting another body they too
will be infused with his Consciousness
that means that if Dr bright wanted to
he could have multiple versions of
himself existing at once initially the
anomaly that Dr bright had become was
treated with suspicion and fear by the
foundation they were dealing with an
intelligent and now Immortal
Consciousness capable of replicating an
unlimited number of times in theory he
could even place his Consciousness into
dangerous scps and gain even more power
Dr bright was placed under strict rules
like not being able to interact with
certain anomalies and having his hosts
killed and Switched at 30-day intervals
to prevent him from building replicas of
himself however this caution proved to
be misplaced Dr bright was an extremely
intelligent loyal and devoted researcher
for the foundation and as a result his
restrictions were slowly lifted by the
o5 council much like his father before
him Dr bright Rose through the ranks
becoming both a celebrated researcher
and a director of various sites during
different periods of time while this may
seem like a win-win scenario for all
involved this is a slightly more complex
situation for Dr bright himself in a
routine psychological evaluation led by
Dr Simon glass Dr bright shared feelings
of frustration about his current
situation he felt as though he was
treated differently compared to the
other researchers and given less trust
due to a situation he didn't choose to
be be in but for Dr bright the
psychological effects of having been
fused to
scp-963-1 actually extends far beyond
workplace frustrations and the boredom
and sadness of unasked for immortality
in a conversation with level one
researcher Dr Friedrich Hayden Wright
told him that in a sense he truly was
the heart of the foundation rather than
just one small part in it when asked to
elaborate he said that because of the
gift and curse of immortality he would
go on to outlive all the other human
operatives working for the SCP
Foundation he would remain with the
organization for generations to come
perhaps centuries even and in that sense
would be the one constant from now until
the foundation meets its end when all
else is gone only Dr bright will remain
of course this is just an overview and
we've only just scratched the surface of
Dr Bright's actions and activities
across the SCP Foundation Multiverse but
for now all you need to know is that Dr
bright is still out there and he'll be
carrying that doomed name long after
everyone else with it has fallen whether
that's a good or bad thing is up to you
to decide when a hyper aggressive lizard
or an evil living cow heart starts
rampaging through your town or a
Sinister salesman turns up in your home
who are you gonna call hint it's not the
Ghostbusters the answer is the SCP
foundation's mobile task force you've
probably heard them mentioned in every
single video on this channel but what
exactly is a mobile task force what do
they do for the SCP Foundation and what
are some of the most famous mobile task
forces in the field let's crack open the
files and take a look in short mobile
task forces are the foundation's Elite
personnel and each task force is
generally made up of highly trained
foundation operatives with specific
skill sets these MTS aren't rooted in
any one base and are relocated to
wherever they're required hence the
mobile part of the name the exact
parameters on what an MTF can be is
pretty Flex flexible the signs of their
units can vary from Whole battalions of
troops packing Heavy Artillery to small
tight-knit groups of intelligence
gathering spies some mobile task forces
are bound to specific scps whereas
others perform more generalized tasks
such as securing certain facilities or
territories when the regular Rank and
file Foundation field agents can't do
the job the mtfs are brought in to pick
up the pieces each group is controlled
by a mobile Task Force Commander who
reports to the foundation director of
task forces though the actual
organizational structure of each group
varies sometimes mtfs which were created
for extremely specific purposes are
disbanded after that purpose is achieved
how many mobile task forces are there
exactly the exact number is shrouded in
secrecy and oftentimes the answer will
depend on who you ask but you're not
here for what we don't know you want to
know the details on the biggest badasses
under the foundation's employee and we
intend to deliver much like our video on
the proposals for scp-001 we're going to
give you a rapid fire crash course on
some of the most most prominent and
interesting Foundation task forces and
remember if you want us to go more in
depth into the most exciting missions of
any of these groups let us know in the
comments but for now it's time for a
rundown of the foundation's best of the
best MTF alpha 1 AKA Red right hand are
essentially the Black Ops of the SCP
Foundation they report directly to the
o5 council and conduct Missions at the
highest level of secrecy with most of
the information hidden behind a level 5
clearance wall many also believe Alpha 1
to have links to the infamous chaos
Insurgency a splinter group at war with
the foundation but if anyone asks you
didn't hear it from us seriously we
don't want to get assassinated ntf Alpha
4 AKA Pony Express are a covert group
deeply embedded into the world's
Logistics and Postal Services the
trafficking of anomalous objects is a
worldwide issue and it's up to Alpha 4
to intercept and keep a lid on those
anomalous objects before they fall into
the wrong hands think of them as a
better funded paranormal USPS police
division one object they've prevented
from reaching the public is scp-3060 a
series of CPAP machines that cause
nighttime visions of frightening
entities MTF omega-7 AKA Pandora's Box
was an experimental task force which
Incorporated the use of Highly combat
effective scps including scp-076 better
known as able the test showed initial
success but after they ran on emissions
Abel's bloodlust proved to be too great
for the team to control and the
experiment as well as the task force
were scrapped however this led to the
creation of MTF Alpha 9 AKA last hope
this is a mobile task force designed to
train viable scps to provide services to
the foundation out in the field this
group has learned the lessons of its
predecessor and has employed the use of
more measured and reasonable anomalies
those include scp-073 or Kane the much
more even-tempered brother of able ntf
beta 7 aka the mass Hatters are the
Elite cleanup crew for anomalous
biohazards chemical spills and
radiological disasters so if an area
suddenly looks like it's going to become
chernobyl's scarier sequel or an
anomalous fast spreading disease as
wreaking havoc over a wide area the mass
Hatters are the guys to call they worked
closely on the containment of scp-1280 a
kind of parasitic nematode worm that
often injects false memories into their
victims MTF gamma 5 AKA red herrings are
the foundation's chief disinformation
division they prevent the leaks of
classified info to the public and on the
rare occasions that this information
does somehow get out they're in charge
of burying it and administering
necessary amnestic treatments to those
affected it's a thankless job but you
won't remember they did it either way
they gave amnestic treatment to the
traumatized victims of scp-1618 a
malevolent urinal which replaced the
user's valuables with disgusting
Alternatives from toilet paper to pig
intestines ntf gamma 6 AKA deep feeders
investigate and track deep sea or
Oceanic anomalies a job that commands
the ultimate respect from people with
thalassophobia that's the fear of the
depot if something terrifying and
mysterious is stirring down there in the
abyss you better believe gamma 6 are
going to be the first ones down they
keep a close eye on a number of
anomalies such as scp-1264 and
underwater amalgamation of sunken ships
eager to drag down more vessels and add
them to its mass MTF gamma 13 AKA
asimov's lawbringers are a specialized
task force devoted to investigating
tracking and apprehending anomalies
originating from Anderson robotics a
group of interests that produces
anomalous robots and machines this
includes examples of scp-2806 a number
of advanced anomalous prosthetic body
parts that wish to attach themselves to
a lacking host to whether they want it
or not MTF Delta 5 AKA Front Runners are
a large group of autonomous Deep Cover
agents buried in various groups of
Interest across the globe it's their job
to gather intelligence from within to
Aid in the apprehension of anomalies
before these groups can get their hands
on them they also sometimes make use of
anomalies to track down others such as
when they requested to use scp-185 a
Russian r-105m radio used during the
Cold War that can receive signals from
any time period including encrypted ones
but can also emit sound waves so
powerful they can literally kill you MTF
Epsilon 9 AKA fire eaters are the
foundation's resident pyromaniacs
they're the ones sent into missions
involving extremely high temperature
environments and they're also highly
skilled in the use of powerful
incendiary weapons if the foundation
needs to burn or avoid getting burned
the fire eaters are the ones for the job
their vital skills assisted in
containing scp-165 massive colonies of
carnivorous parasitic mites that eat
prey to the Bone MTF Epsilon 11
nine-tailed fox are another one of the
most classified mobile task forces
existing only under the oversight of the
red right hand they work internally and
are only dispatched to Foundation sites
when standard protocols fail and
multiple breaches are imminent they were
brought in to deal with the scp-2139
incident a strange psychological
phenomenon that inexplicably increase
the suggestibility of foundation staff
at site-35 this made the infected staff
agree with everything they heard MTF
Zeta 9 mole rats are a task force that
specializes in the exploration and
containment of anomalous areas that are
either enclosed or underground
particularly if due to the effects of
the anomaly the space-time fabric of the
area is unstable you may remember them
from our series on scp-1730 the mission
into and out of the anomalous site-13
MTF 8-10 AKA see no evil are a team that
specializes in taking on dangerous memes
and Cognito hazards that affect the
victims through Visual contact one
example is scp-1561 a crown that when
worn causes all those who see the person
wearing the crown to imagine the wearer
as their King and immediately adopt
positions of servitude while MTF Eda 10
AKA Savage beasts serve the opposite
purpose they deal with musical or
auditory anomalies and anycognito
hazards that work through the medium of
sound like scp-24 402 a chord
progression which can regenerate all
their dying cells MTF Theta 4 AKA
gardeners are a cracked team of agents
who face off against any Botanical or
plant-like anomalies their skills were
put to use against scp-1147 a collection
of plum tree seeds which can grow out of
literally any substance even ones that
are totally inorganic MTF Theta 90 AKA
angled Grinders are a team that
specialize in two of the most
frightening things out there anomalies
and math these brainiacs deal with
anomalous mathematical issues like
warped topologies and geometries even
listing an example of the kind of
anomalies they deal with here will make
your head hurt so just be thankful
they're out there ntfio to 10 or damn
feds are a huge network of undercover
agents based in federal and local law
enforcement agencies across the globe
they intercept any anomalous objects
beings or information and make sure that
it makes its way out of police evidence
lockers and into Foundation hands
without incident MTF Capitan or Skynet
is a temporary team team of combined
meat space and virtual agents tracking
down and disrupting anomalous cyber
threats such as
scp-2987 an external hard drive
basically capable of turning artificial
intelligences into living souls for
trades with soul-consuming anomalies MTF
Lambda 5 AKA white rabbits are a group
that specializes in combating reality
warpers of all types whether they're
messing with space-time or exhibiting
god-like Powers some anomalies even
respond directly to them like
scp-2446 a phenomenon where corpse is
often identical to living white rabbits
team members suddenly manifest around
San Jose California ntf Lambda 12 Pest
Control are a group of agents who
exclusively go after anomalous Vermin
incidentally they're one of the only
mtfs who've never lost members in the
line of duty their purview includes
scp-2810 an anomalous pathogen that
causes the victim cells to become tiny
versions of their own species like a
human cells becoming cell-sized humans
MTF Lambda 14 one star reviewers are
task force that deal with retail
oriented anomalies their main focus has
become combating a Sinister group of
Interest known as the Ambrose restaurant
a chain of extra dimensional restaurants
with strange and anomalous food and
service MTF moo 3 AKA highest bidders is
a mobile task force devoted to
preventing the group of Interest
Marshall Carter and dark limited from
disseminating dangerous synonymous
objects and then obtaining and
containing these objects one such object
is scp-2818 a number of 50 count sniper
rifles that when fired turns the shooter
into a bullet and fires them MTF move 4
AKA debuggers are particularly useful in
the modern age as they track and contain
anomalous electronics and Technology
including isolating and containing
anomalous websites and software one of
the anomalies dealt with by the
debuggers is scp-896 an online
role-playing game that improves the
physical and mental attributes of the
player when they name their character
after themselves remember when we said
you didn't need to call the Ghostbusters
well that was wasn't entirely true
sometimes you need to get MTF moo 13.
AKA Ghostbusters on the line since
they're an MTF whose specialty is
tracking intangible or incorporeal
anomalies particularly those considered
sapiod or sentient and they're on call
24 hours a day to serve all your
Supernatural containment needs like when
you're plagued by scp-1036 which are a
number of haunted Congolese Fetish Dolls
MTF News 7 AKA hammer down are the ones
you need to call when you need real
heavy duty work they're a huge force
with a massive stock of army vehicles
and heavy weaponry and are only called
in for truly catastrophic events they're
also assisted in the containment of
scp-939 the voice imitating amnestic
producing red monsters MTF Epsilon 6 AKA
Village idiots are a group of Agents
whose specialty is investigating and
containing anomalous phenomena that
occur in rural or Suburban areas if you
live in a small town and you're on the
run from a vicious monster you better
hope the village idiots are on their way
they've contained
scp-2561 a cat with a vintage television
set for a head capable of causing
painful tinnitus MTF Pi 1 AKA City
Slickers are pretty much the exact
opposite of the village idiots they
pursue anomalies in densely populated
urban areas particularly in the New York
metropolitan area they assisted in the
ongoing containment of scp-1155 the
incredibly bloodthirsty predatory street
art ntf Sigma 66 AKA 16 tons are
basically the foundation's own version
of The Suicide Squad they're a team made
from captured members of other groups of
Interest who aren't particularly loyal
to the foundation but whose very
particular set of skills make up for
that fact ntf tal 5 AKA samsara are
another group you might remember from
the events of scp-1730 these are a group
unlike any other Immortal cyborgs made
from the Flesh of a dead God who can be
upgraded as needed they're equipped with
experimental and state-of-the-art
Foundation Technology to take on
thematurgic magical and psionic threats
mtf's i-7 AKA Home Improvement is a team
specializing in structural anomalies in
plainspeak they deal with anomalous
activities concerning buildings
containing and sometimes even
demolishing when necessary with a
variety of heavy artillery for example
they counteract the nightmarish scp-3050
a building in North Carolina that once a
year fuses all living matter inside its
own structure on an atomic level MTF PSI
8 aka the silencers are a team devoted
to containing reanimation anomalies and
those who've been affected by them if
you've just come back from the dead then
the silencers are going to want to know
your location MTF Omega 0 AKA ARA orun
are another highly classified mobile
task force that's actually the memories
of deceased Foundation Personnel
preserved on the foundation intranet
system their job is to protect their
surviving co-workers against
informational threats on the servers
they also contain
scp-3664 a damaged but highly Advanced
assault rifle existing in the
non-physical conceptual space it can
only be interacted with by thinking
about interacting with it and last but
not least MTF Omega 12 AKA Achilles heel
is an anomalous task force and these
powerful reality warpers From Another
Dimension hunt down dangerous and
Powerful reality warpers in ours you can
thank these guys for every single day
that our reality continues on as normal
or whatever normal means now their
enemies of scp-3155 members of the
iconic Pinkerton detective agency with
anomalous abilities relating to combat
alright we did it of course even this is
only a sample of the vast number of
mobile task forces at the foundation's
disposal who put their lives at risk
every day to keep Humanity normality and
reality intact they seem to have a task
force perfectly tailored to every threat
we could possibly encounter and as new
threats are cataloged more mobile task
forces are sure to arise to meet them
want more in-depth explorations of any
of these groups and their epic missions
let us know in the comments below the
SCP Foundation is the most powerful
organization on planet Earth thanks to
their cooperation with all World
governments as well as private
organizations front businesses and
Wealthy benefactors they have truly
unlimited funds their ranks include the
best and brightest Humanity has to offer
and even some Minds outside the human
race they have access to Advanced and
anomalous technology from powerful
weapons to memory wiping amnestics
through state-of-the-art equipment that
even Elon Musk could only dream of and
this is a good thing too since we rely
on them to contain thousands of
anomalies and stay vigilant for
thousands or even Millions more
everything from Immortal lizards to
Supernatural sarcic flesh viruses to
Bonafide reality warping demigods like
the deer the gate guardian and the
legendary Scarlet King and who sits at
the tip of this Mighty pyramid
delegating to everyone below and keeping
the wheels turning on this impossibly
large achievement of a group of course
it's the o5 council a group of 13 humans
with so much money and institutional
power they're the closest to
non-anomalous figure can come to being a
god also commonly known as o5 command
the overseers and the OverWatch people
below level 2 clearance at the
foundation have no idea who they are or
if they even actually exist those at
level 3 and 4 know just enough to be
terrified of them and little else
between them they know every single
secret kept by a foundation known for
utmost confidentiality they are the
hungry spider at the center of this web
of Monsters Magic backstabbing and
Espionage noticing even the tiniest of
vibrations on their silk strings nothing
about the o5 council is simple or
straightforward of the information out
there and available about them there's
really no way to know just how much of
it is intentional misinformation put out
there to protect their secrets it's said
that they use complex layers of
pseudonyms and body doubles some say
that each number in the council actually
represents several different people
using the title some say there are far
fewer members than 13 and these are just
a series of smoke screens to avoid
detection some even say to avoid total
capture or assassination at least one
member remains in a space station
orbiting the Earth at all times today
we're going to tell you what we know
perhaps it's true perhaps it isn't but
as with all things regarding the o5
council it's certain to be fascinating
either way we're going to look at the
council's role in the foundation the
kind of staff and the mobile task force
that works around them and some of the
scattered and often contradictory
theories about the identities of each of
the 13 members of this exclusive
Foundation cabal we help you have your
level 5 clearance too where we both
might not make it to the end of the
video this is the SCP foundation's o5
Council like a lot of secret
organizations the foundation goes to
Great Lengths to make sure their
Forbidden Knowledge remains secret
that's why low-level Junior researchers
guards and janitorial staff aren't privy
to where all the bodies are buried both
literally and metaphorically speaking
the foundation has five levels of
security clearance and the o5 council
and their Select Staff are the only ones
who are at security level 5. also known
as thumbnail clearance o5 council
members are also considered Class A
Foundation staff meaning they are of
critical value to the operations of the
foundation as such they're not permitted
to interact with any anomalies for fear
of corruption alteration or death though
of course seeing as they're the most
powerful people on Earth they don't
always follow their own rules on this
one in the event of an emergency their
evacuation and transportation to a
designated safe Zone becomes a top
priority to all Foundation underlays
they rarely if ever interact with the
majority of the foundation instead
favoring to use a vast network of
Messengers and go-betweens for security
purposes much like the U.S Supreme Court
being a member of the o5 council is
supposed to be a lifetime appointment
and the deaf and or replacement of a
member of the o5 council is considered a
truly extraordinary event on occasion
there have been rumors of the o5 members
performing power moves and killing their
own colleagues to consolidate control
this type of event is thought to have
been the ultimate fate of Dr Jack
Bright's father who supposedly ascended
to the position of o5 in hopes of
freeing his anomalous daughter from
containment rumor has it that he was
assassinated by his fellow council
members and replaced for his trouble
while the o5 council aren't meant to
interact with any anomalies this isn't
always the case in practice it's
possible that members of the o5 council
make regular use of their access to
scp-006 a small well whose water has the
ability to cure disease and imbue
Vitality Health and Longevity and anyone
who drinks it it's believed by some that
as a precaution against such potential
attacks from powerful reality warpers
and CK class reality restructuring
events each member of o5 carries a small
charm made from the Flesh of a deceased
but immensely strong reality warper this
supposedly creates a pocket of
dimensional stability around them
wherever they go while it's believed
that all members of o5 council are
fundamentally human it's possible or
even likely that many of them have
experienced anomalous alterations during
their Ascent to ultimate power they're
also said to surround themselves with a
number of powerful anomalous individuals
for protection which leads us nicely to
our next Point who works directly with
the notoriously private and inaccessible
o5 Council let's take a look first the
o5 council's muscle mobile task force
Alpha zero one a appropriately nicknamed
the red right hand these are the best of
the best hand-picked for both skill and
absolute loyalty to the council they
work with an extra layer of secrecy and
accept their orders directly from o5 if
the o5 council decides it doesn't care
for you then the red laser dot that
appears on your head an hour later is
attached to the rifle of a red right
hand operative this is a group with a
checkered pass though many of their
members are believed to have splintered
from the group to form the chaos
Insurgency a group in direct opposition
to the foundation though if you ever
bring this up with an earshot of a
member of the o5 council your likelihood
of going mysteriously missing shortly
after is extremely high but it takes
more than just guns to keep the
foundation's mission moving forward the
figure who represents the interests of
the o5 Council on the world stage is
known simply as the administrator this
mysterious eccentric and likely
anomalous figure is the power full
mouthpiece of the council and it's a
role that's been held by a number of
people since the foundation was first
founded the other staff assigned to the
o5 council are sometimes referred to as
the factorum and these are some of the
only people outside of the o5 council
occasionally afforded level 5 clearances
these bodyguards and personal assistants
are often immensely powerful both in the
sense that they wield a great deal of
institutional strength and that their
often powerful anomalies themselves
don't expect just anyone to get elected
to these positions after all only the
very best get to work in close proximity
to the o5 council so this leaves us with
the big question who exactly are the o5
council the short answer is that we
don't know for sure and that the
information we do have about the 13 most
powerful people in the world is often
contradictory and strange first we have
05-1 often considered the most powerful
of the entire Council many believe that
05-1 is one of the occult holdovers from
the member organizations that first
started the foundation and if that's
true o5-1 is likely to be at least 200
years old they've been able to survive
to this age thanks to magical or
anomalous intervention the race and
gender of 05-1 varies between accounts
05-2 is considered to be one of the more
actively anomalous of the o5 council
members while accounts split on whether
they are male or female consistent
elements and stories about them paint
the picture of an elderly person with
Clues to a mysterious past like having
crucifixion scars or consistent ties to
Dr Sophia light a holdover from an
erased timeline o5-3 is consistently
seen as male and largely seen as being
of European descent regardless of the
other details shared he's generally
considered to be extremely intelligent
as well as one of the nicer members of
the council Act acting as a kind of
conscience for the others 05-4 is
another figure considered to be most
likely male and the circumstances of
their entrance into the council are
generally considered to be rather
spectacular whether you believe the
story that they got in by killing the
previous o5-4 during a hostile takeover
situation or that they were the first to
collect the entire little Mr series from
Dr wondertainment 05-5 is also most
likely male and some accounts consider
him to be one of the more front-facing
members of the council he's more likely
to interact with the public than others
and it's speculated that he's the one
who runs the vast network of front
businesses regularly used for cover by
the foundation at large 05-6 is most
likely male and probably of European
descent his reputation is mixed though
some speculate that he was formerly the
foundation's top field agent While
others believe he's a puppet of the
global occult Coalition one of the
foundation's Rival organizations to some
he's known as the cowboy some believe
that 05-7 is a woman of South Asian
descent she's said to be a charismatic
Master tactician and plays a crucial
role in selecting and hiring the elite
staff that work around the o5 council
o5-8 is one of the more mysterious
figures even among the already extremely
secretive o5 Council some speculate that
they may have been assassinated as they
haven't been seen in public for quite
some time though this may just be a ruse
to fool would-be backstabbers 05-9 is
another somewhat controversial figure
within the council some believe that
05-9 is a woman hired to join the
council directly from the public sector
after a scandal others believe that 05-9
is merely the informal title for
whomever is the acting head of the
foundation intelligence agency 05-10 is
widely believed to have vast combat
experience of one form or another some
refer to them as the Assassin lesson a
female former Foundation Hitman who's
likely the most proficient killer alive
others call them the veteran or the Mad
General a former high-level member of
the U.S military it's speculated by some
that 05-11 is a high-level politician
placed by the Council on the United
States Senate to maintain Foundation
control over political questions and
dealings others believe he's an 80 year
old Japanese bureaucrat with self-esteem
issues yet another rumor states that
this person is actually the foundation's
chief disinformation officer so maybe
both of these rumors are just lies meant
to lead us off the track
05-12 is believed by many to have once
been Adam bright father of famous
Foundation researcher and anomaly Dr
Jack Bright he worked his way onto the
council to try to free his own daughter
scp-321 from containment and was
assassinated by his fellow council
members in the process or 05-12 might be
the accountant for the overseer Council
maybe one day we'll know whether 05-12
is best known for being someone who
climbed the ranks of the most powerful
organization in the world to save his
daughter or if he really just likes
spreadsheets with her 05-13 ever
actually existed is hotly debated many
speculate that there were originally
only 12 members and that 13 was added as
a tiebreaker and Council votes others
say 13 was only added due to the modern
occult significance of the number 13.
some believe there is no 13 and it's
merely another attempt to keep everyone
on their toes or there's a rumor that
all of the members of the council are
05-13 taking turns to act as the
tie-breaking 13th vote whatever the case
is with any of the particular members of
the group the o5 council is one of the
smallest and yet most important groups
of people in the SCP Foundation Universe
they're the ones behind everything
hearing every whisper and pulling every
string and if you know anything about
them even the facts you just saw in this
video it's probably only because they
want you to it's the end of the world as
we know it and you're feeling less than
fine that's because some of the SCP
foundation's greatest fears have been
realized and we're in the middle of an
XK Class end of the world scenario but
what exactly is an XK class specifically
how does it fit in among the other
k-class scenarios that the foundation
stays ever vigilant for what are some of
the ways the world can end as a result
of anomalous activity and if one of
these events does unfold what can be
done to stop it well grab your water
filters and head down to the nearest
foundation-approved apocalypse bunker
not that it'll save you because we're
talking XK Class end of the world
scenarios sadly for us there's actually
a huge number of ways that the life and
reality we consider normal can suddenly
disappear these are known to the
foundation as k-class scenarios a
description given to any event that will
severely alter reality or normality on a
global scale there are too many of these
to list right now but the most prominent
threats are SK NK CK ZK and of course XK
scenarios an SK scenario is when another
species or civilization surpasses or
replaces Humanity such as the threat
that the foundation believes scp-1000
poses while an NK or Gray Goose scenario
posits that the world may be overrun by
out of control self-replicating Nano
machines covering everything in Gray goo
CK class restructuring scenarios refer
to a situation in which some kind of
reality warping anomaly irreparably
Alters or restructures reality as we
know it by contrast a ZK Class end of
reality scenario involves an anomaly in
physics causing reality in general to
just cease but the most feared of all
and the most abundant in its potential
causes is the XK Class end of the world
scenario this is quite literally the
apocalypse Armageddon Judgment Day end
times light sound there are well in
excess of 60 anomalies capable of
triggering an XK class scenario and
sadly far fewer that can reverse them
T.S Eliot wrote this is the way the
world ends not with a bang but a whimper
as anyone at the SCP Foundation could
tell you there are plenty more ways the
world can end than that here are some of
the most strange terrifying or downright
interesting examples of anomalous
apocalypses starting with the more
ridiculous end of the apocalyptic scale
scp-871 is a series of over 200 cakes
varying in size and variety of cake if
any of these cakes are eaten they'll be
replaced by a magically appearing cake
within 24
however if the cakes are not eaten
they'll still produce a replacement if
the cakes are damaged but not eaten a
replacement will appear instantaneously
in other words if the replication is not
properly inhibited by the SCP Foundation
there's a considerable risk of the world
being overrun with impossible quantities
of cake it may sound silly but
Foundation scientists have estimated
that an uncontrolled outbreak of
scp-871 would render the world
completely uninhabitable in a mere 80
Days the foundation tracks a number of
frightening scps capable of quickly
getting out of control such as the 100
infectious and deadly prion
scp-008 and scp-610 AKA The Flesh that
hates but none seem to present the same
genuine threat to human life as an
epidemic of global cake duplication
another bizarre anomaly capable of
causing an Abrupt apocalypse is
scp-5092 this anomaly is a strange
phenomenon that EX exclusively affects
every sitting U.S president at 7 53 PM
every single night the president's nose
will begin to itch when this happens
naturally the president will itch his
nose this may seem like an extremely
innocent pattern of behavior but the
true danger occurs when the president
affected by 5092 doesn't act on this
sudden and irritating itch if the
president doesn't itch it will cause
scp-1592-1 to spontaneously manifest
5092-1 is a massive asteroid over 20
kilometers in diameter that manifests
above the North Pole and begins hurtling
towards Earth at incredible speeds if
the president fails to scratch his nose
by 8 53 PM every single night this
asteroid will collide with Earth and
invariably cause an XK Class end of the
world scenario the foundation is
required to keep a constant watch on the
current sitting U.S president for this
exact reason
scp-2950 is in a similar Stitch
situation it's not necessarily always a
potential XK class waiting to happen but
under the right circumstances it
absolutely can be according to the
surface level files 2950 is an anomalous
folding metal chair when sat on for over
an hour it becomes impossible to
convince the sitter to leave the chair
without using Force however as a file
only accessible by a single member of
the o5 council reveals 2950 is actually
an anomaly that takes the form of
whatever the majority of people aware of
it think it is the misinformation about
it actually being a chair has been
spread this whole time just to reduce
its Potential Threat an ancient Tome
from the sacred library of the Serpent's
hand though depicts 2950 as an
all-powerful and Incredibly deadly XK
class scenario threat if this book ever
fell into the wrong hands and its
information was shared it would become a
self-fulfilling prophecy and likely
result in the exact kind of XK class
apocalypse fear
scp-2935 also known as odaf is a
limestone Cavern in Indiana leading to
an alternate world that already
experienced an XK Class end of the world
scenario a complete and total Extinction
event so powerful it even led to the
deaths of thought to be immortal figures
like
scp-682 and Dr bright while the cavern
is thankfully now sealed off it's
believed that the force of pure death
lurking on the other side is more than
capable of causing the same mass
extinction event in our reality if it
ever gained passage here another anomaly
very likely to cause an XK Class end of
the world scenario is a creature known
as the Devourer of Worlds which lives in
a desert-like pocket Dimension Beyond
scp-2317 while the Beast is currently
bound Foundation scientists anticipated
breaking from its bonds and moving into
our Dimension at which point it is
likely to live up to its name and eat
all of us perhaps the most feared entity
in all of SCP Foundation lore the
Scarlet King is an ultra powerful
Godlike being created by the tension
between organized modernity and the
Primal violence of the past the Scarlet
King makes repeated attempts to enter
our reality and his various devoted
Cults do what they can to help him make
the jump It's believed that if he ever
did find his way into our Dimension the
end of the world is an extremely likely
outcome given his seething hatred for
all modern societies some anomalies
don't seem to cause XK Class end of the
world events but they are predicted to
potentially cause them to happen
sometime in the future one such example
is
scp-3769 a seemingly normal scientific
calculator that binds itself to the body
of whatever touches it it then depending
on the number input into the calculator
regresses the biology of the user into
some prior stage of evolution but when
the calculator was tested on scp-411 a
400 year old man who ages in Reverse it
brought and began performing the exact
opposite function to what was intended
it started evolving the subjects it
touched into future stages of evolution
while this works successfully on all
animals tested from octopi to macaws it
killed every human it was tested on even
when the evolution feature was cranked
down to its smallest setting of a single
generation humans it seems are at the
end of the road in terms of our
evolutionary Journey Foundation
scientists have posited that this could
foretell an XK class human extinction
event within our lifetimes though we
don't know what form it will take
another SCP that seems to function as a
grim Omen is
scp-152 this is a large hardcover book
that features startlingly detailed
descriptions of events in the past
present and future the one common
denominator is that the small
differences often about the actions of
the foundation lead to calamitous XK
Class end of the world scenarios in the
book the foundation has found this
incredibly pessimistic work of
literature valuable as an instruction
guide in avoiding becoming disasters
that it predicts but it's possible that
it may somehow predict an incoming XK
that we can't wriggle out of another
Grim harbinger of a potential dark
future is
scp-1678 also known as on London this
sprawling dystopian City Beneath modern
day London suggests an XK class
Extinction scenario above ground caused
by rampaging anomalies getting loose
from Foundation containment the museum
in the doomed underground city displays
a number of dangerous kettier-class
anomalies wrecking havoc on the surface
world for all we know these horrifying
events May someday come to pass for us
at this point it's understandable if
you're feeling a little paranoid with
all these possible XK class scenarios
looming over us from being smothered by
Cake to Doom foretold by a calculator
it's easy to let a sense of hopeless
roll over you and these aren't even all
the anomalies capable of doing this but
never ever fear there are three
anomalies out there that have the
capability to reverse even some of the
most dire XK situations the one hope is
that they can be reached in time one of
the more practical methods is activating
scp-2000 this anomaly is a huge facility
hidden beneath Yellowstone National Park
through a number of anomalous
Technologies 2000 is capable of making
exact copies of everyone who existed on
Earth in the last 20 years the facility
also stores all human knowledge allowing
things to pick up right after they left
off this new race of humans is then able
to rebuild Society from the ground up at
which point the foundation will
re-emerge and erase everyone's memories
of the XK Class end of the world
scenario that started it all
scp-2000 is an effective in all
situations though what if for example
the XK scenario destroyed the conditions
for supporting human life on Earth or
what if scp-2000 itself is destroyed
during the process of the XK class
scenario thankfully when it seems like
all of their hopes have failed there are
two remaining anomalies that can
function as a sort of total reset button
if brought together no matter the
severity of the Apocalypse these are
scp-055 the unknowable anti-mean and
scp-579 another mysterious anomaly known
only by its extensive containment
procedures the combination of the
anomalous effects of 055 and 579 as laid
out in rajat's proposal and the article
for
scp-2998 is the foundation's ultimate
secret weapon for preventing an XK Class
end of the world scenario if the two are
united during said scenario the universe
resets to a time before the XK class
started and prevents it from happening
that's why if the world is ending around
you there is no better hope of canceling
the apocalypse than bringing 055 and 579
together so there you have it everything
you need to know to have a basic
knowledge about the end of all life on
Earth prevent an XK Class end of the
world scenario is like playing an
extremely high stakes game of
whack-a-ball you never really know when
the next existential threat is going to
pop up and perhaps the one that finally
ends at all is closer than you think
congratulations you've just started your
new job at the SCP Foundation as a
junior researcher we help you survive
long enough to retire and collect your
foundation pension but you've got a lot
to learn before you can even think about
that you're here to find out more about
some of the most mysterious entities
known to man and the foundation depends
on you to do your job right or the world
might not see tomorrow but hey no
pressure you're going to hear a lot of
new terminology on the job big scary
words like apollyon and thalmatology and
of course Euclid and ketter the two most
common containment classifications today
we're going to answer a question that's
been on a lot of people's minds what do
these classifications actually mean
and what's the difference between them
first it must be noted that these
classes don't have much to do with
danger as you may think instead object
classes are all about how difficult an
anomaly is to contain and we're going to
take you on a crash course of each of
them and provide some examples so you
can broaden your idea of what exactly
Euclid ketter and all the other classes
of anomalies can be of course while
Euclid and ketter are perhaps the best
known object classes they aren't the
only ones just below them in terms of
severity is the safe class it may be
every guard in d-class's dream to get
assigned to safe scps but this
classification doesn't mean the anomaly
in question is harmless it does mean
that they are easy to contain though
often requiring very few resources or
certain specific activation mechanisms
for example
scp-507 the unwilling Dimension Hopper
the unwilling Dimension Hopper is fully
Cooperative with Foundation containment
protocols earning him the safe class
scp-662 the butler's handbell while
capable of extreme violence doesn't
activate unless someone Rings it making
it safe to store and of course
scp-999 the Tickle Monster earned its
safe rating by essentially wanting to
keep Foundation staff pleased at every
turn and requiring virtually nothing in
the way of containment Euclid comes next
this class actually has the widest scope
of any object class under Foundation
control and the grand majority of
objects fall under this Banner unlike
safe class anomalies Euclid anomalies
require greater resources to keep
contained the Euclid classification can
also mean that containment isn't always
reliable and is often given due to
either a lack of knowledge about the
anomaly or there being some degree of
inherent unpredictability unpredictable
is really the key word when it comes to
Euclid scps anomalies that are either
autonomous meaning they can move on
their own sentient meaning that they're
capable of thought or Sapient meaning
they are partially intelligent almost
always automatically fall into the
Euclid class this is because anything
that moves or thinks on its own is
capable of surprising and unpredictable
Behavior notwithstanding certain
exceptions like the aforementioned
Tickle Monster this brings us to ketter
in the simplest terms you could describe
ketterclass anomalies as Euclid but
worse again this has nothing to do with
how violent or dangerous the anomaly is
merely how difficult it is to contain
ketterclass anomalies often require
extensive resources to fully contain
containment methods are also often extra
thorough and complex though when it
comes to a ketter class anomaly there's
no guarantee the methods will be one
hundred percent effective there are a
number of reasons an SCP can slip into
ketter territory including but not
limited to extreme aggression and its
frequent Escape attempts a existing in
large numbers over a wide area and
having anomalous abilities that make
them particularly difficult to contain
like teleportation or the ability to
walk through walls to better explain
this Foundation researchers have devised
a simple method known as the locked box
test if you were to leave an item inside
a locked box and stop supervising it and
it's still there when you get back then
the item is probably safe if you leave
an item inside a locked box without
supervision and you're not sure what
exactly will happen then it's probably
Euclid if you leave an item inside a
locked box without supervision and it
easily breaks free then you likely have
a ketter object on your hands or rather
did before it broke out and ran off
before we go any further it's worth
briefly mentioning that there are two
other primary object classes that cover
most scps that aren't under the safe
Euclid and ketter Banners these are
thumbnail and neutralized thumbnail
anomalies are scps that are used to
contain other scps
such as scp-3000 the legendary amnestic
producing anatashisha neutralized
anomalies are objects that either have
lost their anomalous qualities or been
straight up destroyed a good example
being
scp-1762 the cardboard box which used to
contain the land of fantasy but back to
Euclid and ketter what are some good
examples of Euclid and ketterclass
anomalies in containment right now let's
take a look at some of the foundation's
most iconic Euclid classes first kicking
things off we have
scp-096 also known as the shy guy we all
know and fear this self-conscious serial
killing monster that murders anything
that sees its face as you already know
when someone sees the face of the shy
guy nothing can stand in its way on its
quest to utterly destroy them the
monster has not only proven successful
in causing Mash casualty events it's
also pretty much indestructible and has
shown that it's able to tear its way out
of containment with ease so you may be
one wondering why is the shy guy Euclid
and not ketter while it may surprise you
to hear this
scp-096 is actually closer to safe than
ketter the monster may be incredibly
dangerous when its rage state is
activated but it's proven fairly easy
for the foundation to control this
activation the only times that 096 has
breached containment is when photographs
of its face have been found out in the
real world but as long as the foundation
can prevent people from seeing its face
it poses no real risk of containment
breach the very fact that the foundation
can't know for sure how many photos of
it are out there adds an element of
unpredictability to its containment and
that is why despite being incredibly
scary and dangerous 096 is firmly Euclid
next another Euclid anomaly that needs
no introduction
SCP-173 also known as the sculpture this
nasty piece of Modern Art has given
workers at the foundation many a
sleepless night thanks to its terrifying
tendency to snap the necks of anyone who
isn't looking at it this is a creature
so scary that even scp-682 feels
uncomfortable around it much like
scp-096 173 has also proved nigh
impossible to kill and in a Containment
Breach it's been known to stack up
bodies like it was Judgment Day so why
just Euclid rather than ketter once
again it all comes down to how the
foundation understands just how 173
ticks as everyone knows by now 173 is
paralyzed whenever someone is looking at
it as a result the foundation has been
able to devise containment methods that
center around keeping 173 constantly
observed the reason it's Euclid rather
than safe is that while quite reliable
this method is also somewhat time and
resource intensive as with anything that
requires a high degree of human
involvement the potential for human
error is always there and finally in our
rundown of famous euclid-class objects
we have
scp-3008 more broadly known as the
infinite Ikea this Sinister retail giant
is a pocket Dimension hiding within an
Ikea Superstore leading to what seems to
be an infinite Furniture Warehouse
filled with scary faceless creatures
known as the staff hundreds or perhaps
even thousands of people have become
trapped in scp-3008 and it may even
connect to other dimensions this is one
place where you really really don't want
to get stuck while shopping for a new
piece of furniture but it's still Euclid
why well because to the best of our
knowledge there's only one Gateway into
3008's pocket Dimension inside our
reality and the foundation has that
specific sight on lockdown while there
are still things we don't know about
scp-3008 the foundation has been able to
secure and contain the entrance it's
Euclid rather than safe because this
entrance still needs to be patrolled
regularly lead to ward off any staff
attempting to escape and prevent further
victims from entering which is a low
risk but resource-heavy job next up is
ketter class first we have the
terrifying scp-682 also known as the
hard to destroy reptile anyone who's
seen our videos on this nasty creature
knows that it really really lives up to
that name 682 may not be the most
dangerous SCP especially with Cosmic
monsters like the Scarlet king and the
Devourer of Worlds out there but it's
one of the most hearty thanks to its
incredible adaptive abilities because of
the way 682 adapts to pretty much any
threat it's virtually impossible to
attack it the same way twice however if
being violent and indestructible was all
it took to become a ketter class anomaly
the shy guy would be right there with it
there are two key factors that push 682
into ketter territory it's incredibly
high intelligence and the fact that it
reacts unpredictably to all external
stimuli because of its intelligence 682
is able to actively scheme to escape
containment something it does with such
regularity that the foundation is
constantly trying to terminate it and
because of its adaptive abilities Its
Behavior in response to containment is
often not impossible to predict as a
result of all of this 682 is a complete
nightmare to keep locked up making it
cutter next a cutter class anomaly
that's not quite as well known and not
nearly as ferocious
scp-3663 also known as the tunnel
monster or the cardboard box monster
this entity is as scary as it is
incredibly sad he was once a normal
little boy playing in an abandoned
industrial area with his friends he had
built himself a crude monster costume
out of cardboard boxes but through
anomalous means this costume bonded with
the little boy turning his organs into
cardboard and Twine now it manifests in
pipes and tunnels across the country
approaching nearby humans and causing
paranoia and fear it'll then grab his
victims and transport them elsewhere
leaving them unconscious and afraid but
otherwise unharmed clearly we're not
looking at an anomaly even close to
being as dangerous and deadly to scp-682
but it's still very much ketter why
because the teleporting ability inherent
to
scp-3663 makes it incredibly difficult
to consistently contain along with its
inherent distrust of foundation
Personnel the foundation of yet to
devise a truly effective containment
method for 3663 and its teleporting
Antics so cutter class is where it
remains despite it being mostly benign
and finally
scp-1000 AKA Bigfoot this is one of the
few anomalies that genuinely holds the
moral High Ground over the foundation on
account of them formally being an
incredibly Advanced species he's almost
wiped out by Humanity in the past now
the foundation is feeding everyone the
lie that even looking at one of these
creatures can result in death even
though it can't the reality is that the
foundation helps to keep scp-1000
suppressed fearing that if they ever
regained their former glory they would
surely oppress Humanity just as Humanity
had oppressed them even though once
again it doesn't appear that scp-1000
has any such malicious intentions so why
are these abnormally large and
abnormally intelligent Apes cutter class
once again it all comes down to two
facts tipping the classification scales
and in this case those are population
and dispersion there are a lot of these
creatures out there especially across
North America and the fact they appear
in forests all across the country makes
it incredibly difficult for the
foundation to keep a lid on them seeing
as a civilian simply seeing an scp-1000
specimen constitutes a containment
breach these happen frequently
especially if you run encrypted and
conspiracy circles and are out actually
looking to meet one that brings us to
the end of our crash course on Euclid
and ketter class anomalies we hope you
enjoyed your stay and managed to survive
all the strange and horrific entities
we've covered let us know if you've
enjoyed this video in the comments and
want to see more of the ins and outs of
the SCP foundation's classification
system explained but for now you're
finally ready to start your research
role at the SCP Foundation just make
sure you've got your last will and
testament written before your first day
are you bored with where you work
there's no shame in it a lot of people
are or maybe you hit a run of bad luck
recently and you got furloughed or let
go from your old job it's a stressful
time and you're probably asking what
type of career would be right for me
maybe you want some excitement like
chasing down escaped monsters from high
security containment facilities maybe
you want something a little more
intellectually engaging like joining
some of the world's finest Minds in
finding the answers to mysterious
ancient Secrets or maybe you're the
ambitious type someone with plenty of
hashtag hustle perhaps nothing would
satisfy you more than climbing to the
very top of the corporate ladder into a
position that would make you one of the
most powerful human beings on the planet
if any or even all of these sound like
they describe you then maybe your
perfect career would be working for the
SCP Foundation an incredibly powerful
top secret organization devoted to
securing containing and protecting the
supernatural across the globe and Beyond
you could be one of the thousands of
little turning cogs that keeps this
organization running and keeping the
world safe from Supernatural threats but
you can't even get into your local
Country Club how can you find your way
into one of the most elite groups in
history well we can't pretend it'll be
easy but it's definitely not impossible
today we're going to give you a primer
on the potential ways you could join the
proud ranks of the the SCP Foundation
with help from files and evidence across
the foundation database we figured out
many of the different positions
available at the SCP Foundation and what
actions and qualifications you may need
to make the cut though we can't promise
you won't be terminated vaporized eaten
or sent to a terrifying pocket dimension
in the process first it's vital to know
exactly what you're applying for the SCP
Foundation is a complex group but
thankfully for us it does have a command
structure that's pretty easy to
understand this will help us figure out
the positions on offer so you can update
your LinkedIn profile accordingly there
are two main categories of jobs at play
here we have security clearance
categories which range from zero to five
and we have Personnel classifications
which run from a class to E-class let us
break it down for you level 0 security
clearance covers jobs like Logistics and
janitorial services they're the lowest
entry level of any foundation jobs and
you'll basically be told nothing you
might as well will be cleaning the
bathrooms at a local gym level 1 covers
most of the same jobs as level zero
except that these staff members perform
their jobs in closer proximity to
anomalies so you'll still be cleaning
bathrooms but at greater risk to your
life level two is the most common level
of clearance then covers most of the
jobs you can apply for at the foundation
Junior researchers field operatives
containment Specialists you have a
decent grasp on the strangeness of your
profession but you're still locked out
of the major Secrets level 3 is a step
up and covers most of the senior
research staff project managers security
officers response team members and
mobile task force operatives all of
which we'll discuss more later level
four is top secret and reserved for only
senior administrative positions like
site directors security directors or
mobile task force commanders finally
level 5 which gives access to every
secret the foundation holds and more
this is reserved largely for the o5
council and though is working directly
under them we're not saying it's
necessarily impossible for you to get
into one of those 13 seats of ultimate
power but it's probably impossible the a
through e personnel class are a little
easier to process the further along your
letter is in the alphabet the more
dangerous your job because you work in
closer proximity to anomalies A-Class
staff are considered critical to the
running of the foundation like the o5
council so they're usually not even
allowed near an anomaly d-class as you
probably already know are guinea pigs
regularly thrown into the clutches of
anomalies to see what happens the only
thing worse is E-class which applies to
agents who are already under the active
effects of anomalies and thus are
quarantined now that you fully
understand the command structure of the
SCP Foundation we can talk about
specific walls and what it may take to
find these various job titles attached
to your name we'll start with the lowest
of the low and work our way up to the
top of the pyramid start thing of course
with d-class the upside of d-class is
that you don't really need any kind of
qualifications to join the majority of
d-class personnel are death row inmates
so if you commit a few capital offenses
and get yourself caught you'll likely be
up for consideration after all employee
turnaround for G-Class is pretty crazy
for obvious reasons the downside is that
you really really really don't want to
become a d-class while there are some
rare examples of the lives of d-classes
being improved like the one who was
released to pursue a law degree after
being educated by scp-5094 it's largely
a literally dead-end job but let's say
you're a little luckier than that and
the job you seek while still dangerous
will at least get you a decent pension
and dental coverage we're talking about
the day-to-day bread and butter jobs
that keep the whole foundation running
site staff if you're working on site at
any of the hundreds or even thousands of
secure areas the foundation maintains
across the low you have four different
possible career paths containment
specialist researcher security officer
and tactical response officer
containment Specialists are as you can
probably tell from the name experts in
maintaining containment for anomalies
this career path Forks into two possible
branches in the more active of the two
branches containment Specialists enter
zones of active anomalous activity and
contain the anomaly for transport back
to the nearest operational site to join
this career path you'd likely be
expected to come from a military
background due to the risky and tactical
nature of the job the second branch is a
little less Hands-On these are the
actual engineers and technicians who
work with researchers to devise the
containment procedures for the various
scps for this role you'll not only need
to likely understand physics and
Engineering at an expert level you'll
also need an extraordinarily creative
mind you'll need to think outside of the
box to keep the anomalies in the Box a
occurring theme you'll find when it
comes to Foundation jobs is that you
don't seek out the foundation for a job
if you're the right person and show
potential they'll find you researchers
are a similar story these are the best
research scientists in the world scouted
by the foundation to assess the cause if
you're someone with a true passion for
science with topics including but not
limited to biology physics chemistry
botany and xenobiology and you're
willing to put in the work to reach the
very top of your field the foundation
may just come knocking at your door much
like a lot of prestigious universities
the foundation also sometimes considers
Legacy candidates the famous Dr bright
for example became a member of the
foundation's research Corps because his
mother and father worked for the
foundation and it didn't hurt that
several of his siblings were anomalous
too next security officers more
informally known as guards this job is
worth applying for the paycheck alone as
there's likely some good Hazard pay
attached to it most security officers
perform physical guard duties and are
recruited from law enforcement the
corrections industry and the military
however the other half of the security
officers work in information security
and as a result are chosen for their I.T
prowess and their background in the
intelligence community and finally as
far as site staff are concerned we have
tactical response officers don't expect
to get this job if your background is
civilian though since these special
operatives are the first line of defense
between Foundation sites and external
threats from anomalous attackers to
hostile groups of interest trying to
infiltrate if you want this job you'll
really need to put in the hours days
months and years Rising through the
ranks in the military if you do get the
job though you'll likely be stationed at
one of the larger and more important
sites to remain on Constant Guard for
any potential threats but let's say you
don't want to work on a containment site
maybe you want to travel see the world
get a little excitement thankfully there
are two different career paths that
allow you to do just that field agents
and the mobile task force members the
field agent position is one of the more
accessible in the foundation largely
because of the fact that there are so
many ways in if you're an exceptionally
observant and discreet person this job
is probably for you seeing as it's
essentially being a spy for the
foundation you may be offered the job if
you work in law enforcement the
government or any kind of emergency
service these undercover agents also
infiltrate groups of Interest or secret
societies the foundation wishes to keep
an eye on like the Serpent's hand or the
children of the Scarlet King if you're
in any of these positions or already
work as a field agent for the mainstream
intelligence Community becoming a
foundation field agent may just be your
calling mobile task forces are a little
more extreme they're made up of elite
operatives drawn from all over the
foundation often with a heavy emphasis
on Military experience the more
specialized you are the more likely you
are to land a spot on one of these teams
are you an expert in explosives try for
MTF Epsilon 9 the fire eaters are you an
expert in epidemiology and biohazard
containment join MTF beta 7 dubbed the
Mad Hatters are you a benevolent anomaly
aligned with the interests of the
foundation MTF Alpha 9 AKA Last Hope is
just for you the foundation sometimes
even recruits ex-members of enemy groups
of interests into mtfs on occasion of
course despite there being plenty of
ways into this profession none of them
are easy and the job carries huge risks
due to how often mtfs see combat what if
you've always wanted to be more of a
leader than a follower though you're a
natural manager someone who has all
their anomalous ducks in a row perhaps
you're eyeing the role of site director
the one who all other department heads
on-site report directly to how do you
get your foot in the door it's simple
site directors start off working some
other job for the foundation like
researcher or security officer and
simply climbed through the ranks until
they reached the most senior position in
the site where they work oftentimes site
directors were previously very committed
researchers like Dr Bryant or Dr gears
and finally the biggest question of all
how does one become a member of the
legendary o5 Council due to the
extremely mysterious nature of the
council this one is hard to say exact
information about each member and their
past is shrouded in secrecy but it
stands to reason that any new members
are elected in by a majority of the
pre-existing council members on the
board like Dr Bright's father Adam
bright it is theoretically possible to
work your butt off and get into the o5
council through Decades of pure grit but
you're probably wasting your time the
council works in mysterious ways after
all if we've learned anything today it's
that any job actually worth having at
the SCP Foundation isn't gotten easily
but hey considering the SCP Foundation
has its shadowy fingers and every pie
and its thousands of factions worldwide
are masked by just as many public-facing
front businesses for all you know you
might be working for the foundation
already your researcher working at site
19 for the SCP Foundation just going
about your day minding your own business
you've spent your morning keeping an eye
on the d-classes who are keeping their
eyes on
SCP-173 the clock strikes noon and you
decide to break for lunch where you'll
enjoy the delicious tuna sandwich you
made for yourself this morning you're
sitting alone in one of sight 19's
numerous employee break rooms chewing
the first bite of your sandwich as you
try in vain to wrap your head around
scp-055 the unknowable ante meme when
Ascent wafts pass your nose it's the
worst thing you've ever smelled like a
mix of body odor dirt and musty old
clothes you turn to look for the source
of the smell and suddenly realize that
you're not alone in the room there's a
man standing next to you he's tall with
a scruffy face lined by age he's wearing
a long Woolen coat that dangles past his
knees he doesn't say a word though he's
just staring but not at you at your
sandwich before you can open your tuna
filled mouth to say something his great
coat opens and a long green tentacle
slithers out grabbing your sandwich and
pulling it out of your hands you start
to protest and then another limb emerges
from the coat long and reptilian it
places a single finger upon your lips
and shushes you the tentacle lifts your
delicious tuna sandwich up to the
strange man's face and he starts to eat
it in front of you maintaining eye
contact the entire time then after he
finishes your lunge he just turns and
makes his exit leaving you alone in the
break room and hungry later that day you
request a meeting with your supervisor
hoping to get get some answers about
what you saw in the break room maybe
some compensation for the stolen
sandwich or at the very least a little
sympathy for how hungry you've been all
afternoon but your supervisor does none
of that instead the color drains from
their cheeks and they begin to sweat you
ask what's wrong and your supervisor
murmurs one brief sentence you just met
the most powerful person in the world of
course you've heard of the o5 council
they're the most powerful people in the
entire SCP Foundation both in terms of
institutional control and perhaps even
literal raw power depending on who you
ask they might be a group of elite
Foundation agents and researchers Who
Rose to the very top of the pyramid a
secret room full of Dusty old
power-hungry bureaucrats or a cabal of
super-powered beings that transcend the
bounds of our dimension in short almost
nobody is more powerful than the
foundation's o5 council but who oversees
the overseas years if anyone at all if
they do exist then who's the one figure
in Foundation lore more secret than the
most secretive group imaginable there's
only one answer to this question a
figure known only as the administrator
if you spend some time researching the
Affairs of the SCP Foundation there's no
doubt you would have heard the name
perhaps in a heavily redacted file or
whispered in fear by a site director
worrying about incurring the mysterious
figures wrath today we intend to do the
impossible and we just might end up
terminated by the red right hand because
of it but we're going to gather all the
information available to us and try to
figure out who or what the clandestine
administrator actually is we'll answer
your most obvious question first what's
with those weird sandwich stealing arms
one of the few almost universally
accepted facts about the administrator
is their possession of
scp-262 also known as as the coat of
many arms little to nothing is known
about the coat's history before it came
into the administrator's possession and
given the huge amount of power the
administrator wields within the
foundation nobody has the authority to
press them for further information the
Coates interior is a spatial anomaly
from which a huge number of anomalous
limbs can emerge and perform tasks on
the wearer's behalf it's such a useful
item that the foundation has even
considered weaponizing it for field
agents as the arms emerging from the
coats are able to perform tasks as
diverse as playing the piano with two or
more hands to blocking attacks directed
towards the wearer that otherwise would
have been fatal the limbs themselves are
also varied from normal looking human
limbs to tentacles and pods the
administrator only finally surrendered
the code to the foundation in the end
because it was taking up too much space
in their closet and presumably needed
the room for the next season's most
fashionable anomalous clothing for
centuries though you wouldn't see the
administrator without the many armed
coat that's right centuries another
almost universally accepted fact about
the administrator is that they have a
truly freakish longevity potentially
living for hundreds of years there has
likely been more than one administrator
during the foundation's extremely long
history but each one has survived longer
than any average human it's also a
widely believed theory that the
administrator may have been a key player
in the foundation's initial creation too
there's been a number of potential names
speculated for the administrator
including Frederick Williams Agnes
Peterson Kismet and the Sinister Alias
the spider some believe the
administrator to be fundamentally human
despite certain anomalous qualities
While others speculate that they're the
furthest thing from Human this
interpretation maintains that the
administrator is an entity from a
different dimension known as the plane
where eyes can't follow and has a
freakish body May made from a twisted
charcoal-like material Tangled with wire
mesh and a chaos of different limbs all
hidden under
scp-262 but hey the administrator
species isn't nearly as interesting as
their potential role within the
foundation an issue surrounded with
nearly as much confusion and controversy
as well everything else about them and
just like everything else with the SCP
Foundation the line they feed the public
is often different to the words
circulating within the foundation's
higher clearance levels if you want to
believe the official stories then the
administrator is the liaison between the
foundation and the numerous World
governments that need to cooperate with
them to ensure the successful capture of
anomalies the administrator is only
allowed to edit SCP files not actually
write them due to apparent conflicts of
interest in many ways the administrator
is presented as your typical sleazy
Washington Insider schmoozing with
politicians and government figures to
make sure they remain sympathetic to the
foundation's cause according to
observations from people outside the
foundation who've worked with the
mysterious figure they have a pension
for finely tailored suits expensive aged
liqueurs and the Amorous company of
women despite being a bit of a drunken
horndog though people tend to describe
the administrator as likable and easy to
get along with regardless of where you
fall on the political Spectrum they're
also respected by many and whenever
something upsets them even powerful
world leaders are eager to try and
appease them maybe because they are
described as being freakishly strong
when the situation demands it a even
world leaders can change their minds
when they have their arms Twisted
literally while there's nothing too
outwardly bizarre about this iteration
of the administrator we don't actually
know how much of this is true a fact
that really shouldn't surprise you by
now and if being well-versed in the
world of scps has taught you anything
it's that the SCP foundation's PR and
disinformation teams are not to be
trusted so who can be trusted is there
any perspective on this mysterious
figure that can be taken reliably the
short answer is no not really but we do
have the next best thing Recollections
from some of the foundation's most
trusted researchers and personnel and
even some of the strange historical
figures that I've heard about or even
run into the administrator what follows
are some of their answers to the
question who is the administrator
Professor Kane pathos Crow said ah he's
just something people talk about over
lunch or when they're in between
assignments it kills time and it's a fun
game to speculate on who really calls
the shots in this crazy world field
agent Fritz Willy said I like to tell
people he's my brother Foundation
researcher Dr snorlison said I'd like to
poke at him and see what happens just to
see if any of the rumors about being
made entirely of legs and toes are true
or something like that at least director
Neil ghost said no big deal son the ever
stoic Dr Charles gear said there are no
records of anyone by that name working
for the foundation Dr Iceberg said
whatever the Bossman says goes I'm not
on staff to care about last decade's
rumors Dr glass said I never met the guy
alright he's pretty interesting though
I'd love to sit down and have a chat
with him but he's probably too busy I've
never even gotten a call back about it
the Wild Card doctor Alto cleft said oh
Dr Chelsea Elliott said I've actually
done some research on him earliest
records are about 60 years ago and
beyond that there's some vague
references to a leader most of the
records though are incomplete are just
references by name not much of substance
Dr Frederick Hayden said please leave me
alone Dr Jack Bright said yeah I've
heard the guy you're talking about he's
just a legendary thing from way back in
the day when we thought there were 1205s
we said he was there to be the
tiebreaker people don't talk about it
much now anymore probably because we
don't need icons like that to keep
people together Dr Jacob Kensington said
I think he bought me lunch once Dr
Wright said I heard he lives up in a big
tower at OverWatch and he watches down
on the o5s from the back of a mighty
scale dragon and he flies the skies for
free uh or something like that you'll
have to wait until I finish the book to
hear the whole story Dr kondraki said
well we can't tell you exactly what he
said but it was shortened to the point
and he was later disciplined for his use
of rather rude language in an interview
later suppressed by the SCP Foundation
acclaimed horror writer Stephen King
said of his interaction with the
administrator one of the oddest things
to happen to me out on the road was an
autograph session in Westbrook I think a
larger gentleman approached the table
with a copy of the stand said he was a
big fan now I think I might have been a
little crazy here but when I looked at
his hand holding the book it was green I
asked if he was okay and I looked up
into his eyes they were green too he
said he was fine it was pretty scary
stuff Dr tildeem moose said no no I
don't even think we humor that one
anymore it's like the mid-tier research
staff telling the new people there's a
pool on the third floor nobody really
believes it but a couple people every
year try and ask just to uh check but
yes it's uh more or less dead rumor and
Dr Django Bridge said sure I know him he
hangs out at the pool on the fifth floor
so we return to our original question
who is the administrator do they rule
the SCP Foundation or serve it are they
an anomalous human or a straight up
monster are they a liquor-loving
political schmoozer greasing the palms
of the world's government or a
mysterious demigod who founded the
foundation and guides it on its quest to
contain the anomalous and protect
normality the fact is we don't know and
thanks to Foundation misinformation
campaigns we may never know but much
like the ante meme the administrators
defined as much by what we don't know as
what we do and according to all sources
that's exactly how they like it but what
do you think is the truth about the
administrator just who exactly is
lurking under that coat if anyone at all
cunning liar enigmatic and fearsome are
just a few words used to describe a
particular member of the SCP Foundation
while many of the foundation's
researchers and scientists are a pretty
unusual bunch to say the least this one
might just take the cake and then might
have said cake decommissioned in the
most collaterally damaging way
imaginable similar to the infamous Dr
bright always switching bodies appearing
with all manner of ever-shifting faces
genders and even species this particular
Foundation department head is also no
stranger to never looking the same way
twice in his case he can't be
photographed properly at least not by
any conventional means thanks to some
unknown anomalous augmentation any
pictures taken of this researcher will
have the face swapped with that of a
random animal however these pictures
will always feature the same
characteristic grin much like the smile
of a Cheshire Cat a notorious liar not
to be trusted by anyone Dr Alto cleff is
one of the SCP foundation's strangest
members of personnel for starters Dr
Alto cleff is an even technically his
real name more a nickname that became
synonymous with the mysterious scientist
and served as a convenient shorthand for
his alleged real name you see according
to the entity most commonly known as Dr
clef his real name is actually a sound
unpronounceable by human beings his name
is apparently the a major chord played
on a ukulele this explains why the
strange doctor always carries the
instrument around with him should anyone
wish to refer to him using his real name
on a strum of those strings in fact he
used to go by a completely different
name the ukulele man and sometimes agent
ukulele a thanks to his pre-dilection
for playing the string instrument so
where did the alto clef nickname come
from well that one's easy Dr clef
received this nickname thanks to his
pension for signing off reports with a
hand-drawn alto clef symbol a type of
musical note Dr klaff had long been one
of the more enigmatic and mysterious
scientists working at the foundation he
is perhaps more of an oddity than the
Elusive and Infamous o5 Council
themselves although that one is probably
Up For Debate Alto cleff was formerly an
operative for the global occult
Coalition although he first attracted
the attention of the SCP Foundation a
while before then a number of research
papers cleft published at a redacted
University happened to catch the
foundation's eye mostly for their
bizarre and lurid subject matter much of
the content and even the title of some
of his works are redacted but what we do
know is that one of cleft's papers
describes certain traits that matched an
existing SCP they had had cataloged in
their archive there was no way this
could have been a coincidence somehow
alto clef had knowledge of the anomalous
and had to be considered a potential
risk to security during a conversation
with the agent that was sent to
investigate his strange research papers
Alto cleff was able to convince her to
offer him a job within the foundation it
seems exceptionally unusual that cleff
was able to pull this off as most women
working for the SCP Foundation have
reported that the man possesses a
positively slimy personality so why even
bother to hire this guy if he seems to
be such a creep well it turned out that
the acquisition of Dr clef wasn't
without its advantages namely the
capture and containment of scp-447 this
SCP for anyone who might be unfamiliar
is an anomaly in two parts the first
scp-447-1 is a sphere composed entirely
of a green slime-like substance it's
warm to the touch the the same sort of
heat as an ordinary human body and has
no adverse or harmful effects on anyone
that comes into contact with it
scp-447-2 is a viscous green slime that
is excreted by the main ball this
excretion can be eaten or can increase
the fuel efficiency of gasoline by 150
percent when they are mixed the sphere
and the substance are only known to be
harmful when they come into contact with
dead bodies although what exactly occurs
when this happens has been redacted by
the o5 council nonetheless Dr Alto cleff
was reportedly instrumental in
retrieving scp-447 and given the
usefulness of its slime to the
foundation the doctor had in turn proved
his own worth the consensus seems to be
that while his personality might be
annoying or even outright repulsive in
some instances alto clef is still able
to perform his job with precision and
competence making the doctor a useful
asset to the SCP Foundation during his
time there cleft became well known for
being somewhat of a gun enthusiast as
well in fact he earned his own brand of
infamy for his habit of brutally
decommissioning dangerous scps and you
can probably guess what we mean by that
in other words clef established himself
as the foundation's go-to Executioner
sometimes he's a little too good at his
job though in one instance clef brought
a chainsaw to work that he thought
possessed Supernatural properties
however this happened to take place at
the foundation's annual costume party
causing the doctor to think that a riot
was taking place thanks to Personnel all
being dressed as d-class chainsaw in
hand cleft murdered half of his own
research staff without a second thought
it also turned out that the chainsaw
hadn't had any anomalous properties in
the first place that was an HR nightmare
Dr clef is renowned for having brutal
efficiency not shying away from causing
the deaths of countless civilian lives
during his decommissioning of anomalies
as long as he is able to kill or contain
an SCP to further the course of science
or protect the majority of the civilian
world then cleft will view any possible
deaths and collateral damage caused by
his actions as acceptable losses in
short he is a necessary evil but perhaps
clef's best known attempt at
decommissioning an anomaly was during
the scp-239 incident also known by the
nickname of the witch child
scp-239 might appear to be a harmless
eight-year-old child but she's actually
a powerful reality-bending anomaly with
impervious indestructible skin her
capabilities are almost Limitless and
she can influence the world and people
around her in virtually any way that she
can imagine as long as she is conscious
and can see her surroundings
scp-239 can create living matter or make
it disappear wishing things into or out
of existence with as little as a simple
thought or as her file in the SCP
archive 5 puts it if she can see it she
can change it although scp-239 was being
contained by the foundation given a
pre-approved list of spells that she was
allowed to perform and kept calm at all
times so she wouldn't think to cause
harm to herself or anyone around her Dr
klaff didn't think that this was
adequate enough in a report he claimed
that the witch child's containment
wasn't suitable and that she posed a
major security risk to the SCP
Foundation and its Personnel you see
given his time with the global occult
Coalition Dr clef had become somewhat of
an expert in anomalies with the ability
to reshape reality making him
particularly wary of scp-239 it was his
proposal that the foundation should not
overestimate its own ability to contain
These reality Benders and that they
should instead strike first Dr clef's
idea was simple use some form of sharp
Implement to kill scp-239 of course
given the witch child's impenetrable
skin this is a lot easier said than done
but clef had a few Solutions handy to
work around this firstly his plan was
that this decommissioning would be
carried out at night when scp-239 was
asleep and as a result her reality
altering Powers would be neutralized
second the implement used to kill her
would be made out of scp-148 the telekil
alloy this anomaly is a metal that the
foundation keeps stored in blocks that
has the unique property of being able to
block telepathic and memetic effects now
that plan on its own might sound fine on
paper that is if you're on board with
murdering an eight-year-old SCP while
she's asleep you monster but there were
a number of risks for cleft to consider
scp-239 could wake up during her
termination and would then be able to
resist being killed but another far more
complicated risk was that scp-239 could
wake up receive the person carrying out
her termination as a friend as someone
who wouldn't harm her and her abilities
would then alter the world around her to
make this the case changing reality to
match to try and avoid this outcome Dr
clef volunteered himself as the one who
would carry out the procedure with his
mysterious past dealing with reality
changing anomalies as a member of the
global occult Coalition he overzealously
thought he was the only man cut out for
the job however in his arrogance clef
made the Fatal mistake of transmitting
his plan openly to Foundation Personnel
instead of using secure encrypted
channels you see over time scp-239 had
formed bonds with a number of the
site-17 staff that had been assigned to
her regardless of whether staff members
had sympathy towards the girl or because
her perception of them had altered
reality and bent their intentions Dr
kondraki had to step in and intervene
and of course this led to an altercation
between the two thanks to kondraki's
efforts Dr clef's proposed plan of
decommissioning scp-239 a defenseless
anomalous child was thwarted even so
during the incident cleff showed how
remarkable and worryingly easy he
founded to outwit the foundation's
defenses and security forces though he
walked away from his attempted murder of
scp-239 with a few severe injuries
cleft's career wasn't impeded upon in
the slightest in fact the o5 council
promoted him to the position of
department head for the SCP foundation's
division of training and development
thanks to his reputation for Swift
Relentless and surgically precise
methods of terminating scps however Dr
clef's actions during the scp-239
incident prompted some within the
foundation to take a closer look at his
past a tricky thing to do especially
seeing as clef is known to be a liar and
not someone to be trusted and that this
has been a long time habit of his that
is unlikely to change however there does
exist a service record for a global
occult Coalition operative who used to
go by the code name of ukulele first
recruited into the Coalition in 1981.
ukulele was reported to have killed a
number of known threat entities or ktes
but these usually came with the result
of heavy casualties including the deaths
of other GOC operatives one Colonel
Richard Adams is quoted in ukulele
service record as saying does anyone
know who this guy is or where he came
from he's good at what he does right but
every time I ask him about his past I
get a completely different answer
eventually after 99 confirmed kills of
anomalous entities the operative known
as ukulele expressed a desire to return
from active service within the Coalition
this request was granted and sometime
later he resurfaced working for the SCP
Foundation under a new name Dr alto clef
naturally Dr clef has never confirmed
nor denied that he is in fact ukulele
although his habit of playing the
instrument does seem to imply that there
is some sort of connection there after
all that's not as strange as some of the
other rumors floating around about our
old friend Alto cleft some think he's an
incarnation of the Devil Himself or that
he even married a goddess and had
several children with her others claim
clef is the biological father of
scp-166 a girl with deer horns and the
ability to make anything man-made
corrode then again you'd be better off
coming up with your own answer than
asking Dr Cliff about his past he's
hardly likely to give you a straight
answer providing he doesn't accidentally
kill you on the spot congratulations
you've just entered the employ of the
SCP Foundation as a junior researcher as
you know the foundation doesn't just
hand out positions like this to anyone
to get scouted as part of their research
core you need to be one of the best and
brightest you're going to be working
with strange mind-bending and sometimes
even deadly anomalies on a daily basis
you're part of the thin redacted line
between normalcy and absolute chaos of
the supernatural but right now only one
question is on your mind where will you
actually be working because here's the
thing the SCP Foundation station is a
worldwide organization devoted to the
containment of the anomalous and they
have thousands of classified sites and
areas across the globe each of them
specializing in a different subset of
the strange depending on your particular
area of expertise there's a number of
foundation facilities you may hope to be
assigned to but that's not what we're
talking about today instead we're
focusing on the sites and areas so
dangerous that just getting a sign there
feels kind of like a demotion to d-class
the places with the deadliest anomalies
and the most frightening locales that's
right it's time to cross your fingers
and hope for the best because today
we're going to discuss the most
dangerous SCP Foundation sites in areas
but first there are some things we need
to understand about Foundation
facilities in general if you're somewhat
familiar with the world of the SCP
Foundation you've probably heard phrases
like research site and biological
containment area thrown around a lot you
may have even picked up most of the
meanings from Context Clues but before
we throw you into even more dangerous
uncharted waters we're gonna break down
the labels for you the foundation has
secure facilities all over the world and
they deal with a wide range of different
anomalies so these facilities often have
to specialize to suit the requirements
of their specific task for starters the
term sight and area aren't
interchangeable sites are covered
Foundation facilities that often exist
relatively close to civilian populations
so as not to arouse suspicion from the
public or rival groups like the chaos
Insurgency they disguise themselves as
boring government and corporate
buildings areas on the other hand
typically have to contain much more
dangerous anomalies areas tend to not
only be much larger than sites they're
also further away from civilian
population centers there's no cover
story here the areas are just entirely
hidden they also often have some pretty
crazy Fail-Safe measures in case of a
large Containment Breach like one or
even multiple thermonuclear Warheads
designed to detonate and blow the
facility to Kingdom come if things ever
get truly out of control it goes without
saying that you'd probably rather be
assigned to a site rather than an area
if you're risk adverse both types of
facilities are divided into sections or
sectors which in some cases are further
divided into units units typically are
small high security areas devoted to the
extensive containment of a single
anomaly or several closely related
anomalies now that you know the two
types of facilities let's talk prefixes
the handy little descriptor that often
Clues you into how a foundation site or
area has specialized there are 10
possible prefixes for a facility and
we'll take you on a quick crash course
through those before we start getting
dangerous armed as in arm site armed
area or armed section refers to a
facility or section that possesses a
large quantity of Firepower and could
mean military-grade Weaponry vehicles or
just a large number of permanent armed
guards armed facilities tend to be more
dangerous to work in either due to a
greater threat of containment breach or
due to a high possibility of attacks
from the outside biological or bio
implies that the facility or area deals
with infectious or biohazardous
anomalies that would make catching the
black plague feel like a spa day
containment is an obvious one these
sites are areas that are you guessed it
built for containing anomalies
dimensional containment facilities or
sections often contain dangerous pocket
Dimensions or gateways into other
dimensions humanoid containment
facilities or sections deal largely with
intelligent human or human-like
anomalies capable of understanding and
following instruction they're similar to
standard prisons but for anomalous
People Protected facilities and sections
are anomaly free safe zones so we won't
be discussing them much here provisional
facilities are typically temporary
facilities built around an anomaly that
couldn't be feasibly transported to a
pre-existing facility the rare reliquary
facilities or sections are designed to
hold anomalous artifacts of a religious
or historical nature research facilities
are sections either research the
anomalies themselves or work on devising
new containment methods and storage
facilities are designed to store
non-anomalous items long term the
foundation also has observation outposts
but with some rare exceptions your
greatest risk at one of these is dying
of boredom with that out of the way
let's get to what we've all been waiting
for the scariest deadliest and most
overall dangerous facilities on the
foundation roster the places you never
want to be assigned to if your life
depended on it and in this case it
really does first we'll discuss the most
dangerous sites and then the most
dangerous areas so grab your
foundation-issued sidearm and let's go
first sight 19 it shouldn't be surprised
that the largest operating Foundation
site is also the one containing some of
the most famous and deadly prisoners two
in particular are the one you can't look
away from and another that puts you in
lifelong mortal danger if you look at it
these are
SCP-173 the sculpture and
scp-689 the statue of death if you get
assigned to site 19 there's a
possibility you may suddenly find
yourself with a snapped neck while
filling in spreadsheets and if you so
much take a glance at scp-689 you'll be
declared an E-class and possibly even
terminated by your superiors second
provisional side 45 11 home of
scp-4511 also known as the swine God
this giant pig-shaped furnace has had a
terrifying effect on the foundation
Personnel stationed at the site in just
a few weeks it had seemingly rational
researchers and guards performing brutal
sacrifices in its name and ascending
into an occult hell it's happened at
least once already and is extremely
likely to happen again so you definitely
want to avoid being deployed here but
the most deadly sight of all is one that
doesn't even come from our universe site
13 also known as
scp-1730 this site run by director
Elliot Emerson function like an anomaly
slaughterhouse in another dimension
anomalies were murdered and burned and
dissenting Foundation employees were
treated horrifically but when director
Emerson happened to turn on the reality
warping thresher machine this site
became a full-blown nightmare filled
with Escape scps memetic hazards
otherworldly nightmare gods and a truly
unsavory entity nicknamed leechboy who
is quite interested in drinking your
blood if you can even survive long
enough in site 13 to meet him that is of
course it's the secure Foundation areas
where the horrors really unfold these
can make some of the worst sights look
mild in comparison let's take a look at
some of the foundation's most dangerous
areas first containment area 25b this
area is not only 200 meters beneath the
ocean it's also one of the most heavily
fortified and one of the few to actually
detonate its on-site nuclear warhead in
the past that's because this is the
containment area for
scp-076 also known as able this anomaly
has frequent and extreme violent
Containment Breach attempts often
brutally slaughtering staff in the
process with his deft swordsmanship
accepting a job here is a great way to
Fast Track yourself into becoming human
Sushi next up is area 354. this facility
houses
scp-354 also known as the blood Pond a
slowly expanding pool of red liquid that
habitually unleashes dangerous monsters
that attack the guards station there
these include giant bats huge metal
spheres releasing concentrated radiation
beams a giant reptilian humanoid
impervious to gunfire and an invisible
robotic Terminator entity that managed
to murder 90 of the attending guards
before being killed itself in other
words not a recipe for stable employment
area 126 is dangerous for a number of
reasons first that it's located inside
war-torn Damascus Syria and thus
sometimes come under threat from
shelling operations second because it
contains
scp-3989 this spatial anomaly in the
middle of an an olive Orchard turned out
to be a front for a terrifying sarkic
Dimension full of fleshy Abominations
what's more simply being in this area
slowly caused the staff to lose their
minds and become devoted to the sarkic
deities hidden within the dimension and
much like the blood pond it's believed
that this area of influence is actively
growing day by day meaning if you work
at area 126 it's actually getting less
safe with each moment that passes next
arm reliquary and containment area zero
two this space is specifically designed
to contain highly dangerous hostile or
otherwise hazardous anomalies including
multiple cutter class objects and we're
not kidding when we say dangerous and
hostile the anomalies housed on this
side are so dangerous there's a literal
Battalion of armed guards to keep the
peace it also has not one but multiple
Fail-Safe nuclear weapons designed to
literally erase the entire base from
from existence if ever there is a
catastrophic Containment Breach one
particularly horrifying anomaly in area
zero two is
scp-743 this is a seemingly innocent
chocolate fountain that actually
contains billions of extremely violent
ant-like creatures that will swarm
anything nearby tearing it to pieces and
dragging the pieces back to their nest
inside the fountain these insects will
stop at nothing and can even tear
through titanium if they need to in
order to get their desired sustenance so
being present in this area means your
life is constantly at risk hope you like
chocolate next is the dreaded armed
biological containment Area 14 which
contains some of the deadliest
biological anomalies out there from the
bloodthirsty kill-crazed Heart of
Darkness
scp-058 to the Head devouring cannibal
giant
scp-082 to the voice imitating memory
wiping red pack Hunters SC
939 this space Also houses several fast
breeding killer parasites and a few
highly infectious and deadly diseases
while Area 14 does boast an entire Army
of guards with heavy military hardware
for preventing all these terrifying
monsters from breaching containment and
causing Havoc that probably won't make
you feel much better if even one of
these things escapes at any given time
you better hope for your family's sake
that you have a good life insurance
policy and finally area 37 as it stands
being sent to this area pretty much
guarantees either death or a fate even
worse than dying that's because area 37
is no longer under the control of the
SCP Foundation instead it's become a
twisted playground for
scp-1765 a trio of terrifying reality
warpers known as the sisters these
Unstoppable monsters claimed the area as
their own and began performing sickening
experiments such as being forced into
maddening time Loops designed to drive
you insane or being crushed and burned
to death in deadly games with confusing
rules while heading into other areas
offers the possibility of a gruesome
fate area 37 offers a dead certainty now
not only do you know the difference
between different types of sight
scenarios you now know some of the most
horrifying and deadly examples of each
so you know which to avoid but look on
the bright side if you're hard up for
work and the SCP Foundation seems like
an appealing job at least you know there
will likely always be a position
available at one of these sites after
all positions here open up very
frequently you're a member of an Elite
Mobile task force tracking down an
anomaly in a rural Village somewhere in
the Swiss Alps that was recently
detected by SCP Foundation field agents
according to all the current Intel
you're dealing with a particularly
deadly and hard to contain monster a
shape-shifting entity that can kill with
a touch and assume the form of anyone it
kills if this thing somehow escaped the
village and broke into a major
population Center it could blend in
perfectly and cause death on a massive
scale it's up to you and your team to
get this creature secured and contained
before that can happen you're going in
heavily armed with Advanced sensory
technology and several Attack
Helicopters each one loaded with plenty
of powerful missiles one way or another
you're putting a stop to this thing but
the best laid plans of mobile task force
agents go often awry the mission is a
bloodbath the shape-shifting anomaly has
Blended in perfectly with the innocent
civilians living in the village before
you know it half of your team have been
killed and you don't know which of the
remaining team members are really
themselves this really couldn't have
gone worse and if you mess this up not
only is you your life at risk but so are
the lives of everyone this anomaly
happens to get close to all of your
superiors were killed or transformed in
the battle with a shapeshifter and
you're now sitting at the top of your
mtf's chain of command the way you see
it there's only one option you radio up
to air support alerting the several
attack Choppers circling the village you
tell them to rain fire and destroy the
whole place that's the only way to be
sure to take out the anomaly things have
gone beyond the point of easy
containment you sprint past the village
limits as the volley of missiles and
firebombs raise the formerly quiet
settlement to the ground other than the
task force members in the helicopters
you're the only Survivor over 320 people
are dead but on the upside the remains
of the shape-shifting anomaly were found
amongst the rubble by Foundation
Personnel you prevented whatever Horrors
it would have caused if it had been
allowed to escape mission accomplished
but it's not over yet when you solemnly
returned to the containment site you've
been deployed from your superiors order
you to go pay a visit to conference room
2. you correctly assume that it's some
kind of disciplinary meeting maybe the
site director chewing you out for shoddy
work but ultimately congratulating you
for doing what needed to be done under
pressure after all making the tough
decisions is what working for the SCP
Foundation is all about but when you
arrive in the conference room you're
sitting across from a woman you've never
seen before she's tall with hard Stern
looking features and a plain but
well-tailored suit despite being a
hardened soldier on the foundation
payroll something about this woman makes
you nervous she smiles and says hello
I'm with the foundation Ethics Committee
we need to have a word for reasons you
don't quite understand you start to
break into a cold sweat the Ethics
Committee I thought they just existed to
scare Foundation employees I didn't know
they had actual Authority but that's
where you made a terrible mistake and
from the tight smile on on the agent's
face you can tell that the foundation
Ethics Committee has a lot more power
than you've ever imagined perhaps you
know them from the jokes that float
around the foundation circles how many
members of the Ethics Committee does it
take to change a light bulb none the
Ethics Committee can't change anything
perhaps you heard about the o5 council's
disdain for them those bureaucratic
pencil pushers with all their rubber
stamps and red tape the jokes don't seem
so funny now though the Ethics Committee
representative clears her throat and
tells you that you've been reassigned
effective immediately you're now under
the employ of the foundation Ethics
Committee and this change is
non-negotiable you try to State your
case in blind panic part of you thinks
that being reassigned to the Ethics
Committee after the mistake you just
made is Code 4 being taken into a
windowless room and shot in the back of
your head but the agent insists that
really isn't the case the Ethics
Committee hates codes and euphemisms
they don't say terminated they say kill
because of the Ethics Committee Clarity
of language is extremely important they
don't sanitize any horrific acts that
need to be performed for the sake of
containment after all it's their job to
look these Horrors in the face and give
the final yes or no on whether they're
carried out as you may know the SCP
Foundation is essentially above all
external law no government no
organization and no individual can tell
them what to do the 13 members of the o5
council have almost unlimited knowledge
at their disposal as well as technology
that the rest of the world could only
ever dream of with a setup like that it
would be easy to give in to corruption
and go mad with power if they wanted to
they could abandon their mission of
protecting Humanity from the shadows and
instead rule the world with an iron fist
that's where the all-important role of
the foundation Ethics Committee comes in
as Uncle Ben once said with great power
comes great responsibility just as the
o5 Council wields the power the Ethics
Committee wields the responsibility they
remind the whole organization that they
are here to serve the world not the
other way around think of them as the
conscience of the SCP Foundation they
decide what's morally acceptable for the
foundation to do in pursuit of its goals
to make sure that those who fight
monsters don't become monsters
themselves as Nietzsche famously said if
you gazed long into an abyss the abyss
also gazes into you right now you very
much feel like you're staring into the
abyss as the Ethics Committee
representative calmly explains the
situation to you an important thing to
remember about the foundation is that it
must be cold not cruel the second that
the harm it causes is in excess of the
positive results of the foundation's
actions it's time for the Ethics
Committee to step in and Dole out some
discipline it is the ethics committee's
job to balance the moral cost of every
action performed by the foundation for
from the degree of collateral damage
permissible in the field to the ways
that d-classes can be ethically used in
testing while some hardcore Foundation
loyalists may say that people like the
Ethics Committee are standing in the way
of true progress giving yourself holy to
the mission without any ethical
safeguards can be a dangerous line to
walk at that point what's separating the
foundation from the global occult
Coalition or the chaos Insurgency or
even worse their nightmarish alternate
selves from the universe of scp-1730 and
scp-5000 while the foundation
occasionally needs to do some truly
horrific things in order to secure
contain and protect it is the Ethics
Committee that keeps them on the moral
High Ground all of this seems pretty
complicated to you as you sit still
fearing for your life in conference room
too the Ethics Committee agent explains
that it's actually all quite simple once
you get used to it the Ethics Committee
uses a moral framework known as
utilitarianism think of it like product
of morality and math specifically the
committee uses an ethical system known
as negative utilitarianism this system
revolves around the principle of harm
reduction the committee tries to modify
every action taken to cause the least
amount of possible suffering in a
situation the goal being to eliminate
any unnecessary suffering from action
take your decision for example the
Ethics Committee representative says
your actions namely the destruction of
the village caused a great deal of
suffering however considering the damage
the anomaly could have caused after your
team lost control of this situation it's
clear that your motivation was
ultimately pure harm reduction I admire
that kind of thinking in a high pressure
situation you feel a Cool Wave of relief
wash over you it feels safe to assume at
this point that this probably isn't just
a big front for your immediate
termination the agent sitting across
from you seems to sense that that's what
you're thinking and assures you that
she's being nothing but honest with you
the ethics commit city has no need to be
Petty they know everything after all and
that's not an exaggeration their
clearance is basically the equivalent to
level five the highest in the foundation
every line ever redacted from an SCP
Foundation file they were privy to every
secret the foundation has ever kept they
have absolute access to and every
decision the foundation has ever made
the Ethics Committee has always had the
final say with veto power even over the
o5 council and most importantly all
members of the Ethics Committee are
former Foundation Personnel site
directors researchers mobile task force
operatives all people whose decisions
have caused pain and death much like
jury duty the responsibility is random
and non-negotiable what you're
experiencing right now isn't a normal
disciplinary hearing it's an employee
orientation the cruel irony for a
department of the foundation devoted to
ethical conduct is that it's actually
complicit in pretty much all of the
foundation's worst moral crimes after
all every action that the foundation has
ever performed has been performed with
the permission and cooperation of the
Ethics Committee take the infamous
procedure 110 Montauk used to prevent
the victims of scp-231 giving birth the
Ethics Committee had a key role in
designing the horrific procedure and now
they have to live with the soul-crushing
knowledge of exactly what that procedure
entails and soon you will too just one
of the many per subjoining the committee
it isn't the easiest job the
representative tells you she's got the
Steely blank eyes of someone who has
seen some things that people were never
meant to see she continues before we
conclude the first part of your
orientation I suppose I should tell you
about the sowing Circle that'll give you
a good idea of what you're in for she
tells you that the sewing Circle was the
anomaly discussed in the 2017 Ethics
Committee round table it's an anomaly so
secretive that it was never given an
official containment number or
classification but it was proposed as a
solution to one of the foundation's most
nightmarish problems the shortage of
human infants it is an ugly truth about
the foundation that a decent number of
anomalies such as
scp-2845 the deer require the sacrifice
of live children as part of their
containment procedures for years the
foundation has been stealing children
from orphanages for the use in these
rituals but the selling Circle could
solve this problem it was a mummified
human corpse wreathed in the circle of
its own dried out intestines The Mummy
produced seeds which if consumed could
allow human women to produce litters of
12 babies with an 8-hour gestation
period like the litters of a sound hence
the name this would solve the baby
shortage handling it was the job of the
Ethics Committee to decide what would be
the most ethical way to use this anomaly
in the end despite their own personal
moral disgust at the actions their
philosophy of harm reduction LED them to
one conclusion using the device to
impregnate already brain dead patients
effectively turning them into comatose
infant factories whose only purpose was
to be used in horrific containment
procedures But ultimately the sacrifice
would pale compared to the pain averted
seeing as Millions if not billions would
be under threat from some of these
entities being released not that this
makes the knowledge of what needs to be
done any easier to handle on a personal
level but of course after what you did
at the Village you know this feeling all
too well already the pain and the guilt
you felt at making that decision is
going to follow you your whole life and
now you're about to have countless more
experiences piled on top it's your
burden your duty your job the Ethics
Committee agent forces a weak smile she
says of course nobody said the job was
easy but somebody needs to do it it
almost goes without saying that the
inner workings of the SCP Foundation are
kept secret from the general population
your average Joe doesn't need or want to
know about the terrifying entities and
bizarre experiments happening behind the
closed doors of the various Foundation
research sites but there are some
secrets of the SCP Foundation that even
its own staff know very little about one
such mystery is the highly classified
and immensely powerful o5 Council or
OverWatch Council that oversees
everything that goes on within the SCP
Foundation they are considered the
highest Authority within the
organization but very little is known
about them in fact according to one
official report in the SCP Foundation
archives the o5 council does not exist
at all stick with me here there are
Decades of reports concerning the
council there is a wealth of historical
evidence point to their existence and
influence but they do not definitively
exist at least they don't right now take
a deep breath try and untangle the knots
we just tied in your brain sit back and
listen this is the story of
scp-001 the o5 council itself in 1965
SCP Foundation administrator William
Cohen Was preparing to leave his
position to prepare his successor HV
Oleander administer Cohen drafted a
series of letters intended to pass on
important and highly guarded knowledge
to the man who would take his place in
the letter administrator Cohen explained
that he was retiring early for a
specific reason writing a dark language
to my mind sticking to every neuron and
slowing my every thought in truth I'm
unwell Cohen's decline had begun eight
years prior in late 1957 after the
launch of Soviet space probe Sputnik 1
into the Earth's orbit the foundation's
interest had been drawn to the probe
after a foreign signal had been detected
trying to communicate with it not a
signal from a foreign Nation mind you
but something from much further away and
likely something that was not human
whatever it was it was trying to
communicate and it was getting closer on
January 4th 1958 the signal stopped and
an unidentified object arrived on Earth
Cohn was summoned to the War Room at
site 00 much to his surprise it was
highly unusual for guests to be invited
to the site there they worked together
to identify the nature of the situation
with Sputnik until a single burst of
gamma radiation was detected and
sputnik's orbit began to Decay the
council panicked calling heads of state
and calling for as many resources as
possible they had worked themselves into
a frenzy and were planning to shoot down
the first space probe in Earth's history
eventually the decision was placed in
Cohen's hands let the probe land on its
own or shoot it down overwhelmed by the
council's intensity Cohen told them to
do what they thought was best they shot
it down he did not want to but he
crumbled under the pressure there were
so many of them and only one of him and
they seemed so certain in their decision
this was the first decision in his
career that Cohen regretted and it was
presumably followed by many more he
continued in his letter saying and now
what credibility do I have left to
disagree with them I'm but a mouthpiece
a sad old puppet Tangled Up and caught
in the very strings used to make him
dance Cohen wrote his letter to a
successor with one warning Josh as I
have shown you vulnerability here in the
hopes I might gain your trust please
consider asking the same from those who
would insist you trust them in March of
1958 following the incident with Sputnik
the o5 council collectively submitted a
note to the foundation's leadership
committee they stated simply the
individual you call your administrator
has proven insufficient we solicit you
to make your preparations and nominate
another no individual members of the
council wrote in but rather submitted
their thoughts as a collective as if
thinking together as one single mind the
language used was also curious saying
your administrator rather than our
administrator the o5 council seemed to
think of itself as something separate
from the SCP Foundation its own entity
rather than simply a powerful arm or
leader of the organization itself on
June 11 1962 another notice was sent out
it read Foundation a life lived in
service of the greater good is
invalidated if death does not also serve
on November 11 1965 a third notice was
sent out this time to all Foundation
staff please join us in remembering the
life and career of administrator William
Cohen the only constant is change
because of this the erosion of his
skills abilities knowledge and
confidence was inevitable administrator
HV Oleander took over the position for
many years after Cohen's demise in 1988
he prepared to step down and drafted a
letter to his successor Natalya
ellingbrook like Cohen before him
Oleander tried his best to explain where
he went wrong in the hope that she might
do better Oleander began the letter I
used to have such an ego this job this
life and the burdens that surrounded
crush and squeeze you until all you have
left is what they force you to keep my
mind and my soul feel as though they've
been contorted into the shape of someone
I no longer recognize my predecessor may
he rest in peace described his years as
if he were trapped behind Smoky glass
and made to watch a foggy world passing
by like some sort of foyer I too feel
imprisoned but I realized that it was
never Looking Glass it is a mirror the
events detailed in the letter began in
November of 1985 after a powerful storm
had ripped through New England and
caused severe damage to site-31's power
grid during the power outage a
multi-stage Containment Breach occurred
in an unnamed infovor escaped from the
facility The Entity was lost until March
of 1986 when it was detected in a
government facility in Warsaw Poland
determined to make up for his previous
failure Oleander organized a mission to
bring the entity back into custody his
team tracked it down and was prepared to
apprehend the entities host when the o5
council expressed concern that this
Behavior might cause an international
incident and intervened the Council made
the decision to reach out to local and
international governments in Poland
allowing The Entity to escape to pripyat
Ukraine Oleander and the council went
head-to-head on this pushing and pulling
and becoming increasingly aggressive on
either side Oleander could not make up
his mind about what to do listen to the
council or trust his own gut on April 26
1986 his indecision resulted in a
nuclear disaster in Soviet territory not
only that but the entity still evaded
containment the mission was a complete
failure the o5 council submitted a
report on the incident stating we
recommended that the healing process
commenced by first assigning blame the
collective good would be served by
purging liability and we would have
helped anyone would have helped why deny
it by now the pattern has probably
become clear to you the administrator
and the council fall into conflict over
a difficult decision something goes
horribly wrong a new administrator is
chosen the former administrator writes
them a letter to prepare them for the
heavy demands of the judge job and the
cycle begins again as you might expect
during those days of her Administration
oleander's replacement Natalie
ellingbrook sat down to write a letter
of warning to one Michelle Wilkes who
was chosen to replace her Ellenbrook
began her letter as you've likely
surmised from our few meetings I walk
with a pronounced limp and favor my left
leg how I came to be like this is an
especially interesting but what it did
to me might be of interest to a person
in your position any man or woman
changes when they are exposed to pain
simply put it has to go somewhere if you
hold it all within yourself it may stay
contained but it will surely destroy you
when you've had your film it festers in
all the spaces you let it occupy warping
and scarring what used to be healthy
happy tissue sat beneath some people
have hobbies but me I've always just had
my work I've been ringside for so much
pain in my time with the foundation my
predecessor left me a note much like I
am leaving you and in it he warned me of
the tremendous Duty and guilt he hid in
order to do his job although the slings
and arrows of Outrageous Fortune stung
him quite keenly I assure you I have
suffered every bit his equal the breach
at the Olympics in 94 losing control of
site 248 and 96 botch facility transfer
of Hong Kong in 97 bombings in Bali in
O2 the dispute with the Oria in the
Congo in O3 the geoc ultimatum in o4 she
continued although I have weathered much
my tenure is up not with the sort of
precipitating bang that ousted Oleander
but rather the quiet whimper of stepping
away from a battle I no longer wish to
fight I am tired of the council calling
a meeting on every decision I try to
make and I'm tired of calling one on
every decision they try to make without
me I guess that reasoning is another
tribute to the selfish life I have led
my ideal way to say goodbye would have
been to Simply stop coming in my desk
would have sat empty emails unread until
one day a career showed up with my keys
and badge but even here at the end of my
career the o5 council insists on
refusing to let me be by myself so
tomorrow I will play the part of a
dutiful officer resigning her post and
walk away from site 00 with my head held
high and those overbearing bastards in
the rear view mirror I pray that your
head will never be so bound as mine has
administrator Wilkes took her
predecessors words to heart and began
her tenure with a new proposal for
project teffy's the project would
include modifications to the three
gorgeous Dam facility at the Yangtze
River as part of a containment procedure
for entity
2005-c-e-t-011 the council refused to
approve her proposal administrator
Wilkes insisted that they provide a list
of concerns explaining what their issues
with their proposal were the two argued
back and forth over the the necessity of
a meeting until the council submitted
this snow tour we know how important it
is to get off on the right foot although
this body respects you and the autonomy
which you command we have also seen many
come and go you were chosen from your
peers but they have chosen many others
in the past we remain unconvinced before
you Allen Brooke who spent her whole
life pushing others aside so she could
lead she left all others behind trees
with no roots do not hold to the ground
before her Oleander who wanted so much
to be seen as your hero in white he
could no longer live with himself once
his clothes were stained but the sin
does not define the saint before him
Cohen who wanted nothing more than to be
the one who made the decisions he
collapsed in on himself when there was
no easy Victory no man is an island and
a dozen more whose names we have
subrogated you need us you are not
enough administrator Wilkes was offended
by this response and argued that the
meeting was unnecessary she asked for
the council to trust her expertise and
the expertise of her employees they
responded your distinctiveness did not
arise from The Ether you are a synthesis
of available materials and experiences
if needed another could be synthesized
we are needed we are necessary we
synthesize you are not you cannot become
we or become they the choice is yours
administrator Wilkes suddenly understood
the council was not a part of the
foundation they were something else
entirely though she couldn't be
completely sure what they were she knew
one thing for certain they were not her
friends she fired back at the council's
threats you Cast Your Shadow over the
future with your threats and
intimidation certainly we would be
nothing without you but I'm forced to
wonder or who or what would you be
without us I stand with the countless
thousands that have died for our mission
the people that have engineered our
Solutions the people that will build
them and the people that will risk their
lives in order to carry out these
procedures in the hope our mission might
one day be complete without them I know
I would be nothing we are willing to
take our chances without you I'm going
to offer you the same choice you gave me
become we or become they several days
past with no response an administrator
Wilkes made the most difficult decision
of her career she suspended the
appointment of the o5 council until a
day comes when it becomes necessary
again secure area 0-0 has been set up
around the area containing
scp-001 the area has been classified
designated level 6 or Cosmic secret the
coordinates of this secure area are
stored in cranial implants placed in 15
carefully selected Foundation leaders
including Ethics Committee members and
site directors these candidates can
participate in voting once a voters
called but are to be kept unaware of
their status as voters until it becomes
necessary if a super majority votes to
decrypt the contents of these cranial
implants the location of secure area 0-0
will be revealed to them if the security
of these implants becomes compromised
kogita.aic will generate a new protocol
and a new list of candidates will be
selected the original candidates will
have the encrypted information deleted
from their minds no one may access
secure area 0-0 at any time for any
reason unless the aforementioned vote
takes place operation protocols defenses
building schematics and all other
information about the site have been
expunged from Foundation records oh well
what's this a new addendum has been
unlocked this is for your eyes and ears
only yes I'm talking to you do not share
this information with anyone else a
retinal scan has confirmed your identity
and the cogito protocol has been
executed you are receiving this addendum
because administrator Michelle Wilkes is
dead after nearly 20 years of service
before her death she prepared a
statement regarding the role of
administrator at the foundation the
addendum contains a message from
administrator Michelle Wilkes to you her
designated successor surprise you have
been chosen as the next administrator
for the SCP Foundation you may be
surprised asking really me yes you you
may not know it but you were chosen
quite some time ago the cranial implant
has been in place for years now it is
ready to be activated Michelle Wilkie's
message is intended to prepare you for
the trials and tribulations that lie
ahead and to encourage you to ask
yourself what kind of leader will you be
are you willing to do whatever it takes
to perform this most solemn Duty the The
Following comes from the former
administrator herself listen carefully
and consider what she has to say your
future at the foundation the fate of
your subordinates and your very Legacy
may depend on it consider now before
fate takes away the luxury of time what
type of person co-worker and leader you
want to be each and every day one of the
administrators before me was challenged
in terms both great and small during
their tenures and I was no exception to
this pattern the office you occupy is
not about the power and influence You
Now command nor is it ever about the
unfathomable responsibility you must now
Shepherd it is instead about the
character integrity and vision with
which you will meet the test of
leadership and should you prove worthy
surmount it you and the people you will
lead must be asked to undertake tasks no
person should ever be asked to carry out
yet Duty and the safety of all mankind
demand that you make this sacrifice for
them for each other if your resolve
should ever falter know that everyone
you lead stands with you we are ready to
follow you into the Blackest Night if
you let us believe in the promise of
dawn but should your resolve ever break
the council awaits they will invite you
to site 0-0 if you ask you need only
surrender best wishes and wilkies former
administrator what exactly is the o5
council that is a question not easily
answered they are not flesh and blood
not individual minds and feelings but
something else entirely they are
collective something that thinks
breathes and votes together as one being
they view the world as two things we and
they as you prepare to take on the role
of administrator keep in mind who you
are be strong be brave be Resolute and
hold on to your sense of right and wrong
but if you ever should falter if you
decide to stop being you and become we
there is always site zero zero remember
even though they do not officially exist
the council awaits Supernatural monsters
are on the loose practitioners of the
Arcane Arts are here to bring about the
end of the world Sinister paramilitary
forces are using paranormal objects to
gain an edge over their enemies in short
things are messed up and when the
anomalous is out of line we all know
that there's only one group you'd ever
think to call the FBI's unusual
incidence unit what were you expecting
someone else sure they don't have the
resources of the SCP Foundation they
don't have the strategy of the global
occult Coalition they don't have the
ruthlessness of the chaos Insurgency or
the Arcane knowledge advantages of the
Serpent's hand but they've got to have
something right right okay maybe you're
not convinced but you will be you may
not respect them yet but you'll change
your tune when you find out that the
unusual incidence unit has dealt with
one of the most important anomalies out
there
scp-001 or as the true experts over at
the uiu call it ca3 short for confirmed
anomaly 3. if the evidence and files put
together by the uiu are to be believed
and who are we kidding of course they
are then they may have the answer to one
of the anomalous world's biggest
questions how was the SCP Foundation
actually formed but before we jump into
the mysteries of ca3 let's talk a little
bit more about the real heroes of
today's story The uiu this secretive
offshoot of the FBI America's Premier
domestic intelligence agency was
personally commissioned by J Edgar
Hoover during the Cold War why for the
same reason that literally everything
happened in the U.S during the Cold War
to get an edge over the Soviets Hoover
was an extraordinarily powerful man in
U.S politics his tenure as FBI director
spanning the terms of eight different
presidents if he wanted to start a unit
of Agents whose sole job was
investigating the supernatural nobody
would dare stand in his way everyone
always talks about the nuclear arms race
going on back in the 1960s but far fewer
people talk about the supernatural arms
race that was happening at the exact
same time World War II coincided neatly
with the seventh occult War an important
geopolitical event that played a huge
role in shaping the global occult
Coalition and a number of high-ranking
members of the Nazi party were believed
to be key figures in this secret magical
War when the Soviets sacked a number of
German cities as part of their offensive
campaigns in World War II they were able
to bring back scores of anomalous items
that the Nazis had been using to
consolidate dark power this didn't bode
well for the United States government
during the Cold War after all the only
thing scarier to them than Communists
were magical Communists the U.S needed
to build up its own anomalous Arsenal
and that's where the uiu came in the FBI
allocated some of its okayest Personnel
to the task most were either agents who
had experienced a paranormal encounter
out in the field or who were being
punished for some kind of heinous
mistake they'd made carrying out their
duties elsewhere despite not being the
best of the best these agents sure were
eager to get their hands on some cans
that isn't an innuendo by the way the
foundation refers to anomalies it deals
with as scps or skips the GOC calls them
parathrets and the uiu calls them cans
again short for confirmed anomalies well
when it's an anomalous event or location
anyway anomalous objects like cursed
books or supernaturally powerful weapons
are referred to as carts or confirmed
artifacts and finally anomalous people
or sentient entities are referred to by
the unfortunate name of can man it may
not sound as cool but hey it gets the
job done just fine in the end while the
unusual incidence unit May lack the
knowledge strength resources and even
cred of its fellow groups of interest
that doesn't mean that it doesn't keep
track of the others in fact the uiu has
a pretty unique relationship with each
of them the GOC for example is nicknamed
the suits by the uiu the official uiu
orientation states that the suits
outrank them and if they're asked to
follow an order by a member of the suits
they should just go ahead and do it same
goes for members of the fireworks which
is the uiu lingo for the chaos
Insurgency unlike the foundation which
generally has the resources to go
toe-to-toe with the chaos Insurgency the
uiu are rightfully terrified of Them
official orders from the top are for uiu
agents to do whatever they say or they
might find themselves getting shot in
the head by a chaos Insurgent or Worse
next the cart Shoppers also known as
Marshall Carter and dark a Sinister
gentleman's club and Auctioneer of
anomalous items official protocol is to
raid any deals being conducted by
Marshall Carter and dark but oftentimes
these raids are unsuccessful because
mcnd's security Force are more competent
Fighters than anyone on the unusual
incidence unit payroll on the other hand
of the spectrum are the can collection
the official uiu nickname for the
Serpent's hand uiu leadership recommends
against their agents staging any
one-on-one confrontations with them
official memos also contain the phrase
if they give you an order consider
following it they can probably set you
on fire with their mind and finally the
most important relationship of all is
the one they have with the SCP
Foundation much like the rest of the
groups of interest on their roster the
uiu is subordinate to the SCP Foundation
their agents happily taking orders from
them at the drop of a hat they call the
foundation the Skippers but don't let
that casual name fool you the SCP
Foundation is so far above them on the
pecking order that they rarely even
communicate in any official capacity
when the foundation talks to the uiu
it's always through code they will
wouldn't dream of letting a hapless uiu
agent helping them on any major
operation but laser agents of the
foundation might occasionally Outsource
work to uiu agents if ever one of these
Plucky feds receives a message starting
with hey Skipper they can be sure
they're about to have a low priority
anomalous case pawned off on them the
uiu are so subservient to the SCP
Foundation that it has sometimes
resulted in truly humiliating Mix-Ups
one high-ranking member of the uiu once
took orders from a pizza delivery guy
because he thought that pizzeria's name
the spice Crust Pizzeria which could be
shortened to SCP was actually a coded
plan sent by the foundation to deliver a
message rather than a deep dish
pepperoni and cheese incidents like this
are why nobody takes the uiu seriously
but according to them there was a time
before all of this that time ended on
September 7 1954 when ca3 or scp-001 is
the foundation would later call it for
first appeared on the uiu's radar it
seemed to be the most standard can you
could possibly imagine an anomalous High
School building causing a disturbance in
the suburbs of small town America the
uiu received the call after a number of
students claimed the interior of their
schools suddenly looked completely
different than it ever had before
despite there being no records of an
official Remodel and we're not just
talking about moving furniture and a new
coat of paint either the official ca3
file logs a number of changes these
include but are not limited to all the
walls in the building becoming steel
reinforced concrete all the windows
being blacked out from the inside all
student desks personal effects textbooks
and any other standard equipment left
inside the school simply disappearing in
the night the entire floor plan of the
building seemed to have shifted with
rooms altering in both dimensions and
location as well as featuring seemingly
random modifications within none of this
matched up with the building's original
blueprints which were obtained by the
uiu shortly after the can was reported
but things got even stranger for
investigating uiu agents the building
now contained 17 computers each with
state-of-the-art Magnetic core RAM and
advanced cyber security for a Suburban
High School in 1954 it goes without
saying that this was extremely
impressive the weirdest of all was the
fact that a large and seemingly
impenetrable steel wall had appeared in
the auditorium blocking it off and
leaving whatever was taking place on the
other side a complete mystery naturally
the uiu did what little they could to
investigate the matter the first
investigation group they sent inside
team ca305 never came back out and team
ca306 the team they sent in to locate
and retrieve the first team also
disappeared within the anomaly classic
uiu expertise at work almost a month
after discovery and initial containment
a strange noise began emanating from the
auditorium shortly after that the
building became filled with people all
walking around and working at different
operations eerily everyone there had a
resemblance to members of Team CA 306
the rescue team sent in to save the 12
members of ca-305 all of whom were still
unaccounted for three months later the
strangeness escalated more noises came
from the auditorium and the anomalous
people inside the building had gathered
around the steel wall within there was a
hole in the wall six feet in diameter
and every three minutes for several
hours the people in the room would
appear to simply pull an anomalous
object out of it the items were then
carried away and placed in one of the
many rooms that used to be classrooms
before being locked up the people within
the building then seemed to start
guarding these strange items others
started performing tests with what
seemed like far more advanced technology
and methods than what was possessed by
the uiu during the 1950s what was going
on here a few days later several armed
guards exited the building and began
guarding the perimeter when uiu
Personnel attempted to lead an assault
on these guards they were quickly
overpowered even when advancing with
vastly Superior numbers whether this was
due to the skill of the guards or the
incompetence of uiu Agents is still very
much an open question though strangely
enough Intel bleeding out from the
inside confirmed that the people within
were treating their anomalous items with
uiu containment and testing protocols
which is consistent with the knowledge
that ca-305 would have had it seemed
almost as though o5 or copies of o5 were
creating a new Splinter organization
from within and soon enough it wasn't
just confined to the interior of the ca3
building anymore ca-6 a can man that the
uiu had been tracking outside the school
was suddenly kidnapped and shoved into a
black car by two assailants who appeared
identical to agent Dixon a man who had
been a member of Team ca306 the black
car then returned to the ca3 facility
and was allowed to enter into the
complex by the armed guards ca-6 was
then removed from the car by the Dixon
clones and placed into containment in
one of the classrooms it wasn't long
after that that the anomalous people
within the ca3 facility made direct
contact with the uiu outside they sent a
message in Morse code on May 1st 1965.
the people sending this message
identified themselves as the o5 council
a name that seemed to be taken directly
from the o5 Recon team sent into the
facility months ago they identified the
new organization that they just
constructed within the confines of the
ca3 facility the SCP Foundation they
just opened their very first containment
site this New Foundation expressed the
desire to become allies with the unusual
incidence unit but sadly for them it was
essentially the last time they'd ever
really be relevant if this Foundation
origin story is to be believed and as
with all entries under the title
scp-001 it's worth taking it with a
healthy dose of skepticism then the uiu
witnessed the birth of the organization
that would quickly go on to outperform
and overshadow them a big win for
Humanity in the quest to secure contain
and protect ourselves from dangerous
anomalies but another owl for the uiu so
here's a statement that won't blow
anyone's mind the SCP Foundation is
really really really weird we're not
even talking about the actual anomalies
they contain sure this top secret
organization puts in the time and the
effort to make sure menaces to society
like the hard to destroy reptile the
Scarlet King and even the horrifying bad
joke Tomatoes stay behind lock and key
but sometimes you need to hold the
mirror up to yourself and see just what
the heck is going on I mean seriously
think about it this is an organization
that uses live human beings farmed from
Death Row as test subjects considering
how rarely the death penalty is actually
employed in the Western World these days
you know some shady strings are being
pulled there in what about the o5
council the leaders of Humanity's last
line of defense against anomalous chaos
and according to some accounts there are
group of vain Patty and morally bankrupt
individuals who regularly use anomalies
like scp-006 the Fountain of Youth for
their own personal benefit and don't
even get me started on the actual
scientists working under the
foundation's payroll that's when things
start getting even stranger of course
there's Dr Jack Bright a man forever
changed by the chance interaction with
scp-963 an anomalous Medallion and one
of Abel's deadly blades now he's an
immortal weirdo whose equal parts
brilliant and a total nuisance so much
so that there's an entire dedicated list
for bidding all of his zanier Antics
then there's Dr alto clef don't even try
to shake his hand given how much this
ex-goc wildcard loves using violence to
solve his problems you may draw back a
stump he specializes in reality warping
anomalies often wields a ukulele because
he's just so darn quirky a oh and he's
very likely the baby daddy to a teenage
nature Sprite after a deliance with a
goddess or oh and um what about Dr
Charles Ogden gears sure he may not look
that strange to the naked eye he's a man
so dull and humorous that gray is his
favorite color and he thinks sugar on
corn flakes is an act of unacceptable
decadence but he's got a whole lot of
strangeness under the hood like the fact
he's such an emotionally unavailable
father that his daughters across
Dimensions have formed a Splinter Cell
of the Serpent's hand where they work
under the collective pseudonym The Black
Queen just to spite him Dr Dan threw
acts of sabotage was personally
responsible for the worst scp-096
outbreak in Foundation history leading
to the end of thousands of lives just so
he could receive clearance to terminate
the creature and he got that clearance
on the condition that the SCP Foundation
would be terminating him for his crimes
as soon as the goal is achieved and then
there's oh my gosh did someone dress a
dog up inside clothes oh my God that's
the cutest thing I've ever seen oh this
is just brighten my day okay maybe I was
being too harsh on the foundation before
whose dog is this excuse me sir that is
extremely inappropriate wait you can
talk of course I can talk you told I'm
Professor Kane pathos Crow one of the
SCP foundation's finest Minds in the
field of advanced Robotics and
biochemistry I have a level 4 clearance
for 343's sake I'm not some common
bloody mutt oh my apologies Professor
Crow I wasn't aware you were a well a
talking dog well yes I imagine there's a
lot you don't know about me isn't there
um I'm a little embarrassed to admit it
but uh that's true Professor Crow our
data on you and your work with the SCP
Foundation is a little sparse yeah take
these files they should give you a good
primer okay I suppose we better take
this from the top then Professor Kane
pathos Crow among a lineup of extremely
eccentric researchers somehow manages to
rise to the very top in terms of sheer
strangeness to get the most obvious fact
out of the way yes while he was once a
human an anomalous experiment did result
in him being turned into a Labrador
Retriever how did this happen you may
ask we have the same question sadly
Professor Crow is incredibly reluctant
to share any details about this strange
and embarrassing incident so we're just
gonna have to accept it for what it is
and move on everyone ready
okay good despite his strange appearance
Professor Crow is actually one of the
more scientifically qualified of the
foundation researchers it's no surprise
that because of this he has a relatively
close working relationship with Dr gears
so much so that he still refers to gears
by his early Foundation code name Cog a
reference to both the legendary Stern
doctor's initials and a pun on his
iconic surname during one incident Dr
gears did tell Professor Crowe to
terminate an anomaly that was for all
intents and purposes a human child if it
presented any difficulties this souers
the wholesomeness of that previous fact
so we'll swiftly move on once again Dr
gears is just terrible with kids like a
lot of foundation researchers Professor
Crowe was personally headhunted by the
SCP Foundation after his academic work
in the fields of advanced Robotics and
biochemistry started Turning Heads This
was just for clarity's sake back before
Professor Crowe was turned into a
labrador Professor Crow spends most of
his time working in BIO research area 12
where he studies a variety of anomalies
but his bookish nature also earned him
another interesting position he's the
SCP foundation's Chief librarian where
his encyclopedic knowledge of anomalous
technical literature has made him a
valuable asset in archiving and
organization this balances out some of
Professor Crow's indiscretions it is
important to specify that Professor
Crowe is genuinely a well-liked figure
among his SCP Foundation co-workers
after all who wouldn't love to work with
an adorable dog in a lab coat and
glasses all day but it's also important
to note that he is also somewhat
mistaken prone with a number of these
mistakes putting him in the crosshairs
of his superiors Professor Crowe has
come close to outright termination
several times perhaps the most out of
any prominent researcher currently
working at the foundation however to
keep himself out of the same Dead Man
Walking category that the thoroughly
unpleasant Dr Dan currently finds
himself in Professor Crowe has a few
aces up his sleeve first firstly he's
got friends in the administrative
Department willing to pull a few strings
to keep him out of Harm's Way hey maybe
they're just very Ardent dog lovers up
there the other thing that's kept him
from being turned into an extremely
overqualified chew toy for scp-682 is
the contents of His Brilliant brain on
many of the occasions where the o5
council have considered terminating him
he's demonstrated the fact he possesses
vital and often Irreplaceable knowledge
saving his furry skin a perfect example
of the kinds of strange scrapes that
Professor Crow gets himself into is the
incident in 2009 where without even
realizing it he somehow traveled through
time and scared The Living Daylights out
of everyone the details are best
expressed here in Professor Crow's own
dictated notes 1802 2009 in all my years
working here there have been few things
which have irritated me cause me
physical harm yes cause me undue stress
yes cause me innumerable amount of
mental distress yes but few things have
just irritated
time travel is one of them I went to bed
on the 15th of January year 2009 at 1 30
a.m I woke up on February 18th at 9 26
a.m of the same year I hadn't moved I
had only nine hours of sleep and to me
nothing had happened then after a
slightly confused day amidst the many
cries of I thought you were dead among
other things I might add I discovered
that I have been missing for the past
month and three days in that time Sophia
had completely taken over my duties
though she had halted all of my personal
experiments and was trying her utmost to
relocate me while keeping my
disappearance from the higher-ups
Apparently
leaving me to sleep in a small
self-contained bubble of expunged and
making at least
which was eventually ruptured by do not
expunged and sending me back to this
phase of space and time needless to say
I was slightly irritated to say the
least
2402 2009 it had me quarantine for
nearly the past week observing me and
running tests to see if they can find
any sort of strange abnormalities with
my physiology my behavior my anything if
I had one more hand shoved up my nether
regions or I'm forced to look at one
more bloody ink plot I'm going to flip
out and go rabbit I'll say they'll stop
the quarantine soon and Sophia says the
higher-ups still haven't caught on to
anything I suppose I'm lucky in that
count normally the only time they
quarantine something is when it's too
dead to be any sort of immediate
security Hazard still I guess I can see
where they're coming from if it were my
decision I'd probably force a quarantine
2 and probably for longer at least they
had the decency to give me my clothes my
PDA and someone to dictate to 1203 2009
I'm still here and I hate it day in day
out it's the same thing get up eat
exercise then simple observation until
lunch then more observation until dinner
then lights out not allowed anything
other than the things I already have and
even then I only got those because
Sophia felt bad me I'm only allowed to
use them every day for an hour at most
otherwise they're also in observational
storage all this wasted time that I
could have been doing something
constructive something useful something
interesting but no I'm stuck here
because of a right twist of fate forcing
me into this monotonous hell they keep
telling me I'll be let out soon Liars oh
505 2009 they've seen fit to release me
I almost thought I was going to die in
there still it almost seems strange to
be out and about again but I do
appreciate being back in my own quarters
my own clothes and my beloved Walker
back by my side Sophia has taken good
care of the facility while I was gone I
think I might actually leave that to her
while I keep to my experiments she seems
to enjoy the great deal suits her
analytical mind
all of my personal experiments are still
waiting for me with the exception of the
040 test logs they simply haven't posted
their findings yet stating that they
needed my approval first so I'll have to
pour through those the first chance I
get I'm interested in the progress she
may have made still there is a good deal
of work to be done and I am more than
ready enough to take it on after all I
have to make up for lost time don't I
it's clear that life isn't easy for poor
Professor Crow much like Dr bright After
experiencing the mysterious event that
turned him into a dog Professor Crowe is
both a researcher and an anomaly and
unlike the superficially subtle
presentation of Dr Bright's anomalous
nature it's hard to hide the strangeness
of a talking dog in human clothes this
bizarre interstatial Zone he occupies
forces the foundation to keep him on an
extremely short leash no pun intended
seriously Professor it wasn't intended I
swear anyway the point is Professor
Crowe isn't allowed to clock off at the
end of the work day like his fellow
researchers to he's forced to remain on
site almost never appearing in public if
the professor wasn't the kind of person
who could easily get lost in his work a
situation like this would probably drive
him insane speaking of you're probably
wondering by this point other than being
the cutest researcher at the foundation
sorry Dr Cliff you're special in your
own way we promise what kind of work is
Professor Kane pathos Crow actually
known for around here Professor Crowe's
most notable body of work is largely
based on an opinion that's pretty
controversial to hold around the SCP
Foundation he believes that they should
be actively utilizing anomalies that
aren't dangerous in order to further
their Collective goals an excellent
example of this is The Cordial
relationship he has with scp-040 also
known as Evolution's child she's a
powerful reality warper who is able to
synthesize new anomalous life from
pre-existing living creatures Professor
Crowe who refers to her as Emma in his
personal writings was initially training
her to do this with SCP p148 the
infamous telekil alloy however he also
filed a formal request to go further
saying I think it's about time we
started trying to utilize 040's
abilities or at the very least allowing
her to use them enough to actually learn
how to control them she will not be able
to rely on the scp-148 hair pieces
forever we theorize that as she gets
older her powers will increase
exponentially possibly to the point
where her unconscious telepathy cannot
be contained he also somewhat infamously
went ham with a series of experiments
using scp-158 a frightening anomalous
device known as the soul extractor which
contrary to its name Professor Crowe
also realized could place removed Souls
into other objects or creatures this led
to the creation of a being that Crow
dubbed zero because it was subject zero
in his experiments to create a composite
Soul using scp-158 he spoke of this
subject somewhat creepily in his notes
zero would make an excellent candidate
for my assistant with respects and
admires me for its creation much as a
child would and endearing father figure
I have assured that it would be treated
well and that I would give it a host to
the best of my ability to create all
that it asks of me is that it be given a
name other than zero a name not a number
I told it to give itself a name to
Christen itself whatever it so wishes it
told me it would have to think about it
like a lot of strange and fascinating
figures everything you learn about
Professor Kane pathos Crow seems to
raise new questions is Crow just a mad
scientist Without a Cause eager to
perform bizarre experiments for their
own sake well not quite the sum total of
all of Professor Crow's work is Project
Olympia a topic that probably deserves a
whole video in its own right and do
sound off in the comments if you'd like
to hear more about the deranged
Frankenstein Project that Professor
Crowe has devoted his life to you see
project Olympia is Crow's baby and also
his attempt to play God through
combining a variety of different
anomalies including all the ones we've
mentioned here and several others he
would hope to create an entirely
artificial living thing that would serve
the interests of the SCP Foundation how
exactly this would be beneficial to the
SCP Foundation is admittedly a little
confusing but seeing this goal through
to its conclusion has become an
all-consuming obsession for Professor
Crowe he's performed countless
experiments with a huge catalog of
anomalies under the project Olympia
umbrella he's written Reams upon reams
of notes and logs on the subject and
produced a huge number of prototypes
he's also used project Olympia as a
pretense to remove even more Souls using
scp-158 because that just appears to be
a strange obsession of his doesn't it
incidentally we aren't the only ones
confused about the exact purpose and
value of project Olympia when members of
the o5 council finally got a proper look
at Professor Crow's work with the
project they released the following
statement all activity related to
project Olympia has been discontinued
OverWatch command has deemed it to be a
gross waste of resources and permanently
remove support for the project with
Personnel assigned to work with it being
moved to Alternative sites a hearing is
to be held with the project
administrators to determine how the
project was able to continue as long as
it did despite the lack of any concrete
results prototypes and other equipment
have been slated to be decommissioned
Professor Crowe took this news about as
well as you could expect but in the end
he always finds a way to wriggle out and
continue doing whatever he wants to do
because that's what Professor Kane
pathos Crow is all about he's living
proof that sometimes you just can't keep
a good dog down alert you are attempting
to view the file on
scp-001 this file is highly classified
and its contents are sealed by the order
of the o5 council by continuing to view
them you are confirming that you have
received prior authorization if you are
found to be viewing these materials
without adequate clearance you will be
terminated if you choose to accept these
risks and verify your credentials access
will be granted in five four three two
one the following is a truncated summary
based on transcripts from an official
meeting of the o5 council you have been
warned 05-1 sat at a conference table
addressing his colleagues all the other
council members looked at him
expectantly except one hello everyone
05-1 began I'm sure you're all wondering
why 13 isn't here today I'll get to that
but I first want to publicly address
something I'm sure you've all noticed by
now after talking to you for the past
week or so I've noticed that we've all
been inducted onto the council almost at
the exact same time all of us except 13
that is in fact 13 probably conducted
your orientation the other council
members nodded that's good to know that
it wasn't just me 05-2 commented I would
have expected the last two to run me
through things o5-1 side indeed in fact
I asked 13 about it but he refused to
say very much of course he pled
ignorance but I don't believe that as
you might guess the previous 1205s did
not retire at the same time they were
killed in fact this building isn't even
the original site-01 that was destroyed
I think you can see where this is going
05-3 frowned so we have a dead 05
Council a missing site zero one and
somehow none of this is on our records
and only one suspect piped up 05-2 05-1
held up a hand drawing attention back to
his words I would like to designate
05-13 as one of our scp-001 projects of
course this will be kept secret from him
but we need to investigate this entire
ordeal until we figure out what happened
how it happened and why 05-13 is the
only one left standing after the
aforementioned conference 05-13 was
designated as cp001
scp-001 is a male human of Latin
American descent standing at
approximately 1.9 meters tall the exact
nature of this entity and the anomalous
properties he possesses are not yet
known he was given his anomalous
classification following the Caesar
incident an event that resulted in the
death of all previous o5 council members
aside from 13 the complete eradication
of the previous site-01 and the loss of
any official documentation on 13 or his
appointment to the council
scp-001 is contained in a modified
containment facility constructed
similarly to other Foundation sites with
the exception of additional living
arrangements for the members of the
OverWatch Council the facility is
equipped with state-of-the-art security
cameras as well as three nuclear
warheads intended as fail-saves these
will detonate if scp-001 breaches
containment one designated member of the
council is to be given amnestic drugs on
a regular basis and maintain official
documentation of all information
gathered about
scp-001 this council member will be
referred to as the archivist and will
hold the position for approximately four
months at a time though they may
terminate their duties sooner if the
monastic side effects proved too
detrimental to their health when a
council member's time as the archivist
comes to a close they must conduct a
meeting to assess what they have learned
o5-1 was appointed to the role of
inaugural archivist and several months
later a second conference was called one
of the subjects discussed was a series
of interviews conducted with survivors
of the Caesar incident though several
members of personnel made it out
relatively unscathed they had no memory
of the incident at all and their
interviews were unfortunately of no help
during the events of the conference
05-10 revealed that he had recovered a
copy of the previous o5 Personnel
dossier it included an entry that
described o5-13's purpose on the council
stating 05-13 special connection to the
anomalous gives him a perspective no
other council member could begin to
Fathom while normalcy confirmation
meetings require a 11 members for Quorum
no meeting is allowed to proceed without
05-13's attendance in addition to this
entry there was a table recording
05-13's various anomalous property
measurements perplexingly his appearance
temperature skeletal structure Corporal
reality and induced emotional states
were all found to be within the Baseline
of normality the remainder of the
conference was designated to deciding
the next steps for a series of
specialized teams looking into the
Caesar incident
scp-001's origin and the entity's
anomalous properties o5-8 was selected
as the next archivist and the meeting
disbanded with a new sense of purpose
the Caesar incident team managed to
identify the geographical location of
the previous site-01 by searching for
records of unusual seismic activity on
the date of the incident earthquake
records led them to an island off the
coast of Greenland where the remains of
the site were waiting an investigative
team attempted to search the island but
was prevented from exploring the room
influence by representatives of the
global occult Coalition who demanded
they leave immediately investigation
into the presence of the GOC on the
island turned up a curious connection
their representatives had spoken with
05-13 before setting up an outpost there
meanwhile the origins investigation team
looked into records of 05-13 at various
groups of Interest reports were
conflicting and difficult to parse and
the team brought their findings to the
third conference notice from o5-8
conference number three was cut short
after an intense exchange led to enough
people leaving the meeting for us to
lose Quorum we archived all the
materials covered up into that point as
well as the efforts made to de-escalate
tension between the members however this
also means that information herein was
not properly vetted by the entire
Council before being uploaded so we add
on the conservative side if you need to
see the full proceedings please contact
the current archivist before the
premature adjourning of the conference
the following conversation took place
05-1 it excuse me for I believe some
clarification regarding the exchange
with Marshall Carter and dark is
necessary how so it mentions here that
you performed an exchange it is
important for the records and for our
general information security that we
know exactly what information was
exchanged yes that does make sense I'm
sorry I did not write that section of
the report if my memory serves me well 7
was responsible for the Marshall Carter
and dark reconnaissance well seven could
you elaborate 05-7 looked at 05-1 and
swallowed you know the rules are pretty
tight on this why did you give them
anything in the first place yeah 11
makes a good point don't we have our own
spies working some of the transport
routes 05-7 nodded and then began going
through her belongings could you at
least tell us what kind of information
you gave them 05-7 passed thought to
herself for a moment and then motioned
to the entire Council wait you gave them
information about us 05-7 shook her head
paused again and then nodded her head
yes she held up a finger and then went
back to looking through her files but
that's no I I don't believe this we
can't let people know about us no matter
the situation imagine if word got out
that the old Council had been killed I
bet cult across the planet would have a
Heyday I thought she said anything
actually important oh really I've only
dealt with the merchants once or twice
but they know how to appraise anything
especially information 05-7 held up an
index finger and then continued looking
through her files are you just going to
ignore the issue then just gonna hang us
out to dry eleven you need to calm down
we're all waiting on you 05-7 looked up
at 05-11 and then put her files away she
gathered her things and left the room
Camp Jake being called out I see 11 I
will need to speak with you following
this meeting you can talk to me now I'll
be in my office 05-11 left the room hey
I'd like to go after seven to make sure
she didn't actually do something stupid
that's fine I believe that would drop us
below Quorum but I believe this meeting
has fallen apart anyway one 12 and I
will make the next update ourselves this
scp-001 conference is dismissed addendum
an update has been added to this file by
05-8 regarding security concerns
following the official ending of the
meeting 05-7 distributed the summary of
all information exchanged with Marshall
Carter and dark the information was
pulled from the out of date 05 dossier
the current explanation as to why it was
accepted by the group of interest is
that it would have confirmed any
information they had gathered previously
about the o5 council as part of the
exchange we have received a tip as to
where to find more information on the
scp-001 which the origins team will
investigate for the next conference 05-7
later clarified in a written statement
that she had left the meeting simply to
retrieve the file detailing this
information since it was not on her
person 05-7 insisted that she does not
need an interpreter due to information
security concerns a discussion was
scheduled between her and 05-1 to reduce
communicational issues at a later date
05-11 issued a formal apology I hope
that this will be a cessation of any
internal conflicts we are working
together and therefore require that a
trusting relationship has been
established between all members as
Abraham Lincoln once said A house
divided against itself cannot stand
05-12 was appointed to the position of
archivist and after several months
passed a fourth conference was called
the following is an excerpt from this
meeting two why doesn't your theme start
us off alright sure we did make some
nice progress always good to start a
meeting on a high note you all remember
those four survivors we talked about
last meeting right we got back in touch
with them and did a more thorough
interview more intense techniques lie
detector tests heart rate monitoring the
whole shebang do you have transcripts I
do but spoiler alert they're not very
different from the first round so we're
now convinced they genuinely don't
remember how far does 13's anti-memetic
side reach slow down there we're not
quite down you see as part of our second
round of interviews we also did a
physical examination and some tests to
see what messed with their heads and we
found they all had a little scar right
on the side of their necks right where
we inject amnestics I mean while I
understand what you're implying we tend
to administer amnestics fairly liberally
last meeting was essentially just a
prolonged reminder of how much we value
infosec true but we keep good records of
who we use with that stuff how much
we're using if we're using the pills or
the syringe etc etc however when I went
to look up if any of our survivors had
ever taken the injectable amnestic all
my results came back negative I also
took the liberty of checking out red
right hand the entire squad's got
injection scars and we rarely wipe those
guys whatever happened I think we
covered it up ourselves when you say
ourselves do you mean oh no no no no I
just mean the foundation if we were
actually involved then everyone here
would have those scars but six nine and
I definitely don't have them so that
leads me to believe they didn't drug us
it would be an all or nothing deal good
work sounds like eight needs to have a
talk with our amnestics department wait
wait wait sorry I'm still trying to keep
all the details in order you said that
they were injected yes see that's what I
don't get we use the injections like 10
years ago we moved on to the pill since
you can miss a vein also I checked our
amnestic supply right after the Caesar
event and we didn't see any variation
from our normal usage maybe the records
are off we found that whatever 13 did
he's good at covering up his tracks I
don't think that's it because you know
who does still use those injectable
amnestics the GOC I see we'll have to
schedule another meeting with our good
friends at the
um as well after discussing potential
Origins for scp-001 the council moved on
to the subject of 05-13's anomalous
properties the anomalous properties team
presented their findings okay so
everyone here has the records of our
measurements also I can tell you now
they are not particularly insightful uh
do you have too many leads to choose
from ah well quite the opposite actually
we have nothing nothing abnormal with
regard to radiation Humes radio
frequencies 13 is almost impressively
normal are you sure we're not going
about this wrong I mean I know we've
kind of Quantified some of our anomalies
in the past but as a general rule
they're not supposed to follow the rules
right that is what I was beginning to
suspect also it is troubling that he can
just hide it from us entirely or there
is the other option we're not only
backing up the wrong tree but we're in
the entirely wrong Forest you're saying
he's not even anomalous in the first
place it sizes at or we're dealing with
God want a God who knows the foundation
better than even veto let's continue to
discuss the non-anomalous options since
it appears that there would be very
little we could do about the other case
so that would mean he's probably an
inside man for the Insurgency or the
Serpent's hand nine nine knots a hand
they don't operate like this he might be
a fifth is fanatic ah that too or maybe
he's with someone else we've seen quite
a bit of the GOC and uiu popping up in
this my apologies but I do find it
difficult to believe that a single
Insurgent would be able to detonate the
on-site nuclear warhead from halfway
across the globe if we believe our
previous information I'm not so sure we
can though it sounds like he spoke to a
regular body double maybe his enormous
properties that he can create body
doubles but what are we supposed to do
with that excuse me I'd like to return
to the earlier line of discussion about
13 being unable to perform the
assassination due to possibly meeting
with our point of contact because I'm
beginning to believe that he actually
did meet with 13. so you believe he was
able to blow site-01 Sky High from
halfway across the globe I mean if we're
going with the god Theory I could see it
no I'm saying he had hell or at least
more than one man helping him remember
how our request to install additional
security cameras was denied by the
Ethics Committee you finally talked to
them I did I met with Mr Huang to demand
an explanation he refused and told me it
was above my security clearance
above your security clearance you're on
the goddamn Council they're simply on
things outside of your jurisdiction you
run the Ethics Committee for God's sakes
Ah that's not quite accurate I'm not in
charge of the Ethics Committee I'm
simply the o5 ambassador to it they need
to be a separate entity to eliminate
bias in various cases so you believe
that 13 is in League with the Ethics
Committee Aussie administrator if it's
set above your security clearance or
both whoever it is they are trying very
hard to stop us from seeing him in
private someone should just let us give
him a full physical he's probably
Baseline this would let us confirm that
yeah but if we're wrong and our God
theory is correct he'll blow our asses
Sky High like the last Council I believe
we need to adjourn here so we have
enough time to prepare for our next full
council meeting to avoid suspicion
although we do not need to expand our
search further I will consider speaking
to 13 before the next conference but I
will only do so if I believe it will not
result in a second Caesar incident are
there any objections to this the council
fell silent then I believe this
conference is dismissed alert retina
scan confirmed identity verified your
credentials have been accepted and
further access has been granted welcome
05-13 you have one new message hello 13.
I'm sure you've been keeping dabs on
your fellow council's progress they're
growing closer than either of us wanted
but I'm not surprised when you get
enough smart people together they tend
to suppress your expectations you're
probably hoping this is going to end
soon I'm sorry you've gone through this
it obviously wasn't in our plan for you
when we inducted you into the council
but if you could keep up our Gambit a
little longer I would be appreciative
I'm unconvinced your cohorts are ready
to know what happened to the
predecessors and I don't want to ask Al
fine and Johnson to help clean up
another May 13th I don't even want the
thought of pulling a Caesar event in
their heads the GOC and the uiu already
have enough dangling over my head as is
but if they do approach you and confront
you about the situation I'd rather you
have a direct answer also transcripts
tend to be more convincing than recall
I've attached here the transcript from
the o5 meeting before the Caesar
incident it's part of the last minute
backup that site01 performed as part of
stage 3 Containment Breach protocols if
anyone asks where those backups are
stored you can tell them the same thing
I told you it's beyond their clearance
love the administrator 05-1 was present
in the o5 council conference room he was
working at a laptop in front of him
beside which sat a cup of coffee and
message flashed up on his screen reading
access granted you have five minutes to
complete an action before the session
automatically shuts down he grumbled to
himself irritated two minutes passed
before the remaining council members
except for 05-13 enter the room you're
all healed right I wouldn't want one of
you to be off site for this Juan what's
this about I know you've been going
through a phase lately but emergency
meetings demand a real emergency oh it's
an emergency all right then spit it out
we have a breach new XK level threat no
it's more of something under two's
jurisdiction we have an internal affairs
issue 05-1 motion to the coffee one of
you bastards thought I would actually
drink this
someone didn't give you enough sugar no
too much arsenic another message flashed
up on the computer reading you have
three minutes to complete an action
before the session automatically shuts
down do you want to finish with that
that pain in the ass can be patient wait
wait wait wait you think one of us tried
to kill you with your coffee oh don't
act like that's below you I know you've
all been out to bury my ass one calm
down I know we've had our differences
but but what it's not like this is the
first time one of you has tried to
destroy me I know you are once tried to
infiltrate one of my transports
infiltrated he was assigned to fill in
for it's no use five the man can't think
straight anymore oh really who's the one
here with his head so far up Marshall's
ass he can taste the curvier you're
accusing me of selling out no no I'm
accusing all of you of selling out or
being out for yourself or some nonsense
you've all gone soft it used to be if it
doesn't make sense throw it in the cage
now it's let's measure it look at it
figure out what it is then make sure
doesn't bother anyone that's not
containment that's sitting idly and
hoping the public doesn't find it my God
we've started Outsourcing to bat
shelters you know if this is a problem
we can just calm down and rethink our
stances on a few things that won't
change anything half of you are under
someone's thumb and the other half of
you are so messed up you need a cell of
your own this is the man who suggested
we drink from the Fountain of Youth well
seven you're right I'm about as far from
Baseline as the rest of you like God
damn it anomalies are essentially
running this organization the computer
chimed in saying you have two minutes to
complete an action before the session
automatically shuts down shut up God
damn it we're getting off topic you said
someone poisoned you what about 13 he's
not even here that's because I sent him
to talk to nobody but why because he's
the only one I trust he's the only one I
don't need to have this chat with he's
the only normal person on this whole
goddamn Council we plucked him off the
streets and just started asking him do
you think this is weird I'm not worried
about someone whose movements we've been
able to monitor since he came out of the
uterus
freaks I don't know what you all did
before you showed up here for all I know
you're just Eldritch Abominations
waiting for the chance to kill me dead
one slow down they were so wrapped up in
their argument they barely noticed the
computer saying you have one minute to
complete an action before the session
automatically shuts down and you know
what we've always been pretty liberal
with containing anomalies now we might
have 12 of them on the council one what
your session just finish it already it's
distracting as all hell you know you're
right I should just finish it already
there's not much more for me to do 05-1
resumed his work at the computer aside
from containing you like the inhuman
aberrations you are but it was a little
too late for that the computer which had
been allowed to timeout said emergency
stage 3 containment for each protocol
activated the on-site nuclear warhead
will detonate in five four three two one
this concludes the file on scp-001 it
appears that in a place dedicated to
studying the strange and unusual where
the bizarre and anomalous have become
The Pedestrian the usual just another
day at the office the most notable thing
a person can be is completely average
when the impossible becomes possible
when you and everyone around you are the
furthest thing from normal the ordinary
is the stuff of nightmares what the heck
is consensus reality and is it really
the answer to everything you may have
seen us mention the subject before
consensus reality after all all is what
the SCP Foundation is trying to preserve
in the face of ever increasing anomalous
activity a kind of Truth or normalcy
that all of us can agree on Pick 10
people at random and ask them what color
is the sky what gases element is
produced by trees has every U.S
president since Washington secretly been
an alien reptile in Disguise the answer
will or at least should be blue oxygen
and no this is consensus reality but no
not really yes in a more casual sense
the state of reality to which we all
agree could be a viable definition of
the term consensus reality but you
likely don't remember being called upon
for a vote along with the rest of
Humanity on what is and isn't quote
unquote normal that's because consensus
reality isn't the consensus of everyone
it's the consensus of the most powerful
beings alive the o5 council in this
instance scp-001 is the ever updating
document that records exactly what
normal is but perhaps even more
important is that anything that exists
outside the council's most recent
definition of normal is targeted for
containment while at face value it seems
less flashy than something like the gate
guardian or the terrifying Scarlet king
or the insane twists and turns of the
oroboros cycle the document defining
consensus reality despite being the only
thing on the database to be given the
classification non-anomalous is about as
foundational as Foundation documents get
literally everything currently in
containment is there because this
document deems it so it is the SCP
foundation's Ten Commandments of
containment and thou shalt contain if
this document was ever leaked it could
lead to a complete broken masquerade
scenario where the anomalous cat is let
fully out of the bag only the o5 council
has access to the document and it's only
through consensus that additions
alterations or removals can be made
naturally it's a document that's in
extremely high demand among the
anomalous Community because it answers
the big question that every anomalous
individual has if I'm not even dangerous
if I've committed no crime that would
necessitate the locking up of a
non-anomalous human why am I still being
contained and don't worry today we're
going to answer that question or rather
the o5 council will but let's return to
the council themselves we've covered
them and there are many interpretations
before from them being a group of
Fantastical Immortal demigods to being a
frightening hive mind to being a shadowy
faction of mysterious emotionless
bureaucrats constantly conniving and
undermining each other to gain just that
little bit more power but what's more
frightening the keys to normality being
in the hands of these Larger than Life
Fantastical figures or in the hands of
human beings just as valuable and Afraid
as the rest of us with only the
knowledge of the strange things going on
behind the curtain to protect them from
the truly unknowable the L5 Council
holds meetings with some regularity
where they ask themselves and each other
whether any new developments in The
Wider World require changes to the new
normal it is up to the o5 council to
define the difference between universal
laws gravitation physical forces and
basic chemistry biology sociology
psychology technology and philosophy and
the kind of crackpot theories being
spouted by people on street corners
carrying the end is nice signs some of
their decisions are quite simple can a
new development be explained by the laws
of an existing non-anomalous framework
if so the rules need not be changed the
current Paradigm of our understanding
can rest neatly in place but other
decisions fall into a gray area in order
to illustrate this we're going to do
something unprecedented we're going to
go into the actual boardroom of the o5
council and see exactly what decisions
they made about our consensus reality
the one that you and I are living in
right now we're going to look at three
different meetings one from 1932 another
from 1945 and an example from as
recently as 2014. so what really goes on
in the discussions that Define what we
all would consider normal the 1932
discussion was spurred on by strange
development happening in the United
Kingdom new forms of occult adjacent
Witchcraft and spiritualism were
beginning to take off descended largely
from traditional Pagan and Wicca beliefs
the fact that some of these Believers
were actually attempting spells was
enough to catch the foundations
All-Seeing Eye and the matter was
discussed by the o5 council 05-3 said if
I have even covering sis there are
traditional beliefs in cultures
throughout history that we do not
consider anomalous we must not use our
position to threaten the right of
humanity to believe with the stern look
05-7 replied except this does not extend
from traditional practices this new
witchcraft is a modern invention
developed through a scholarly re-reading
of practices as an alternative to
Christianity it is not a continuation
and practitioners are attempting spell
casting oh 5-5 chimed in with now soon
you'll say Aleister Crowley has
something to do with it the document is
clear theraji is anomalous religion and
spirituality are not show me proof that
they are casting spells that cannot be
explained under rigorous testing and I
will personally see to containing those
spells myself until then no just as
dilemma is allowed so shall this
witchcraft for God's sake well allow
Satanism as long as they aren't
channeling demonic energies 05-1 the
most senior member of the council nodded
and said agreed furthermore we will need
all the faith we can muster against
lethargic traditions we never know when
a new faith will assist in our cause no
updates to consensus reality were made
in 1945 an event of far greater
magnitude took place the use of
terrifying new weapons by the U.S
military and Hiroshima and Nagasaki that
resulted in the deaths of over 200 000
people the council converged to discuss
the earth-shattering event and what
their reaction to it should be shaking
05-2 said thank you for responding to my
emergency call Trinity has happened I
can barely contained what I saw it was
like the sun rising from the desert sand
a dawn of Destruction and fire that
lasted for miles around I could not
believe that such an explosion could
ever be seen as possible tales and prior
evidence of the summoning of gods have
had less impact I tremble with fear
about the possibility of people wielding
this kind of power the ability to level
a city with the flick of a switch 05-4
replied when the Germans and Russians
also developing this technology we are
at War and this sort of escalation
happens 05-5 said may I remind my
esteemed colleague legs that we are not
at War the United States Japan they are
at War we are not Nations now the
question stands is this anomalous do the
physical effects follow from a
mathematical Concepts 05-7 said hmm they
do follow there's scientific testing was
completed each and every step of the way
to reach this point I do not believe
this is anomalous no matter how
frightening the repercussions are 05-2
still understandably worked up said what
you're just going to let people hold on
to the keys to their own destruction we
have fought tooth and nail to keep such
capabilities out of the reach of man and
now you're saying we should abandon our
purpose 05-5 said we do not prevent
destruction we sequester the anomalous
and as long as we agree that the test
was arrived through diligent scientific
process available to anyone but o5-2
simply wasn't having it he shot Back
available to anyone listen to yourself
man can you imagine a future where any
two-bit dictator chooses to unleash the
fire of a thousand Sons wherever he
wishes maybe the problem isn't with the
equations maybe the whole of nuclear
physics is anomalous itself o5-1 once
again brought his own level-headed
perspective to the table Enrico Fermi
has already received a Nobel Prize for
his work on transuranic elements and
radioactivity we can just secure Nuclear
Physics from the world radioactivity is
everywhere and we end up causing more
contradictions when we try to send
ourselves back to the Dark Ages try
explaining chemistry without referring
to covalent bonds try explaining biology
Nuclear Physics is here to stay and we
had better get used to the consequences
of this no matter how terrifying this
will be for the planet and for Humanity
with a rattling PSI 05-2 once again took
a seat murmuring may God have mercy on
our souls in the aftermath of this
debate the document on consensus reality
was altered to reflect these new
developments in nuclear physics as
frightening as they were I think think
we can all form a consensus on the fact
that one off murder is a less depressing
subject than mass murder and it was a
single murder that led to the o5 council
discussing the concept of worms that
walk in
2014.05-6 came to the table with for
those unfamiliar with the topic the worm
that walks is a Trope in which a
character is actually a writhing hive
mind of worms generally held together as
a single Mass we're not here to discuss
this Trope instead we are here to
discuss the recent conspiracy that has
arisen from it the conspiracy is the
idea that certain individuals are
actually worms that walk and not humans
when asked if this conspiracy had any
Merit to it 05-6 replied and now
individual conspiracy Believers are
divided themselves on who is a worm that
walks and who isn't and all evidence
indicates that there aren't actual worms
that walk in the general populace it
pretty clearly falls under
irreproducible conspiracy theories I
personally believe there's nothing we
need to do or change in scp-001 I'm
another member of the council wasn't so
sure that these results were
irreproducible saying on December 11
2013 a believer in the conspiracy from
Decatur Alabama killed his neighbor
under the belief that the neighbor was a
worm that walks the killer then took a
video of his deceased neighbor and
uploaded it to YouTube claiming it was
proof of the conspiracy and that the
corpse was dissolving into individual
worms before his very eyes he said that
he was going to take a sample the video
was quickly blocked and removed and
everyone who has viewed the video agrees
that the subject is unmoving and does
not dissolve into worms the killer
turned himself into police while
clutching a jar of tube effects worms
and the neighbor sent to the Morgan
County Morgue autopsy confirmed that the
descendant was missing a thumb
post-mortem and killed by a gunshot to
the chest which if he were a worm that
walks would be survivable when
questioned whether these were just the
actions of a single insane man the
council member continued the one item of
Interest was that after the autopsy the
assistant coroner oversaw the return of
the body to the next of kin the
assistant coroner was also a conspiracy
believer and despite not having any
prior contact to the parties involved
screamed and discussed upon entering the
examination room grabbing him up and
complaining about all the worms
everywhere no one else noticed any signs
of worm infestation it was further
discussed that d-classes who were shown
the body didn't see it as anything other
than a corpse however after being told
about the worm that walks tro several of
them saw it as a writhing mass of worms
some believe that this could be a
memetic side effect of actually
encountering a living worm that walks
and updates were made to the document to
reference the possible existence of
perceptual monastic worm triggers so now
you know what the o5 council is up to
when not playing office golf or plotting
each other's downfalls they're having
discussions about witchcraft war crimes
and walking worms you're probably
feeling a ping of curiosity about the
actual scp-001 document especially if
you you're an understandably vindictive
anomalous individual wondering why the
foundation is carting you off to
Paranormal gitmo for the simple crime of
existing and if you look for the true
document and you manage to survive the
memetic kill agents put in place to stop
you then what you'll actually find is
even stranger a letter to you from 05-5
explaining exactly what's happening to
you the letter reads hello I'm afraid
you won't find scp-001 here it's stored
in a far more unreachable location than
this I'm sure you were hoping you could
get in edit it in a couple of places
here and there and voila you're no
longer anomalous you're free to go the
foundation will harass you no longer of
course it can't be that easy but I'm
going to help you you deserve this much
I'm going to tell you why why the
foundation targets you why we deem you
something to contain to persecute after
all there are far worse evils in the
world we keep our record of nuclear
weapons above of as an example there are
numerous genocides throughout history
the death toll from just the flu alone
is far greater than the potential damage
for thousands of the people and objects
we contain and yet we dedicate ourselves
to branding you anomalous something not
normal something inherently wrong
something that cannot be allowed it's
peace why I'm not going to patronize you
and say there's nothing I can do I'm
only one voice on the council and I
can't change things on my own that's
true but the decisions I make and the
way I let myself view your circumstance
are a direct cause of people seeing fit
to throw you into a box even if I can't
change the document I could remain one
more advocate for your normalcy after
all Humanity has believed in ghosts and
spirits for thousands of years we all
believe in the monster under our beds
when we were children these phenomena
are very real and very much a part of
the way the world works why can't we
just declare them normal why won't I
free you from your torment it's because
we aren't only here to secure contain
and protect the world we're here to
secure contain and protect you the
defining feature of the anomalous is
that it cannot be explained through
simple scientific testing this makes you
and your nature different unique even
and that scarcity makes it valuable but
that doesn't mean that your value is
something everyone can appreciate
sometimes it can only be appreciated by
those who would use it against you the
scarcity is also the tool by which a
monster can exploit you others aren't
familiar with your anomaly and won't
respond to descriptions about it as real
this gives opportunity to nefarious
individuals to exploit the lack of
knowledge and use you as an Eldritch
Pawn to their pleasure they can isolate
you consume you make your anomaly their
lover to destroy it's like a sadistic
thirst with your existence I'm sure
you've seen it happen someone is
different their desires needs their
reality forces them to be ostracized by
The World At Large they're left alone
probably not friendless but sidelined
starved for connection that's when
someone swoops in promising greatness
but only offering that connection you
crave through consumption of you
destruction of Your World perversion of
your reality you fight back try to tell
someone of your plight but others
respond well that can't be happening
that's not real you must be mistaken you
are alone in your anomaly and left to
suffer we can't let that happen yes go
ahead point out that we're isolating you
at least as well slowly consuming you
and your existence just as surely as
some abuser might wish to burn you off
call us monsters it's okay but keep in
mind that even in our pursuit of you our
cover-up our incarceration of you we
still want to make sure that you
continue to exist that you aren't
removed entirely from this world you
have every right to exist you have every
right to be as different as you are you
the monsters out there the monsters in
here you are all just as real as we are
just as real as the teeming irrational
self-destructive Humanity that remains
ignorant to your plight and the
conclusion that we are all in the end
the same stuff I hope you can find
comfort in it yes you are a monster but
whether we are deemed anomalous or not
so is every last one of us and that
means you deserve your existence we
secure you we continue we protect you
and even if you still don't get why I'm
doing this please understand that I
still love you now go check out Children
of scp-001 the Scarlet King is scp-999
really his son and scp-001 or borrow
cycle the full story compilation for
more perspectives on the ever elusive s
cp001